Für's Zuschauen.
Guten Abend, hier ist Chaosradio 96. Heute Abend hier auf Fritz geht es um, Andreas, wie war das, eine Sauerei, was?
Sauerei der Sonderklasse.
Eine Sauerei der Sonderklasse, wenn also auch ihr eine Sauerei der Sonderklasse beizutragen habt, ruft an unter 0331 77 97 110. Können wir das auch in ein Wort fassen, die Sauerei der Sonderklasse?
Es geht um Wirtschaftsspielnage.
Was war das für ein Geräusch aus dem Hintergrund? Es hat gemacht und hier ist Chaosradio 96, Wirtschaftsspionage unser Thema im Studio der Andreas, der Andy und der Fefe.
Hallo Fefe.
Fefe kommt so aus dem Hintergrund. Also aus dem Hintergrund müsst ihr jetzt Fefe schießen. Und Fefe schießt. Könnte jemand mal... Was ist das hier? Was ist denn hier für Musik jetzt auf einmal wieder?
Es gibt halt bestimmte Dinge, über die dürfen wir nicht reden, da spielen wir lieber Musik.
War's das? Das war's. Was war das?
Das war ein Song.
Das war der FCC Song.
Genau. Von Eric Idle.
Von Eric Idle.
Ja, von Monty Python. Der, ähm, ich glaube in USA am Radio gespielt sehr teuer werden kann, weil das glaub ich 5000 Dollar pro Fakt kostet. Ich weiß nicht, ob jemand mitgezählt hat.
Nee, er hat's ausgerechnet auf seiner Homepage steht, das sind irgendwie 530.000 Dollar kostet, wenn man diesen Song in den USA am Radio spielt.
Man darf in den USA am Radio nicht Fakt, also kein Lied spielen in dem Fakt explizit.
Nein, es gibt ja die sieben verbotenen Wörter.
Kriegst du sie zusammen?
Das ist aber doch, ich dachte, das wäre nur ein Scherz aus diesem Film mit diesem schlechten...
Genau, die hat Herr Carlin erfunden. Nein, aber die FCC hat tatsächlich Leute eingestellt, die Radio hören und die diese Begriffe raussuchen und dann Strafen verhängen. Und da gibt's also einen Bußgeldkatalog, genau wie wenn man bei uns einen Polizisten beschimpft, gibt's dann halt für verschiedene Wörter und verschiedene Aussagen eben verschiedene Strafen. Und dieser Song ist halt echt teuer.
Wir sollen das Chaos Radio in die USA verkaufen. F*** nochmal, Alter.
Aber das ist ja eigentlich gar nicht unser Thema heute.
Ach so, genau.
Ja, gar nicht.
Ja, wir waren bei Wirtschaftssprünage stehen geblieben.
Ich dachte, wir hätten noch nie mal in die Lande gefangen.
Also wir wollten sozusagen darüber reden, was man mit und ohne Computer machen kann. Und was mit und ohne Computer gemacht wird, nämlich, dass Unternehmen sich gegenseitig in die Karten gucken, zum Beispiel. Aber eigentlich sollte man zur Einstimmung vielleicht mit kleinen Geschichten aus dem Leben das Thema beleuchten. Ich war mal auf einer Veranstaltung eines großen deutschen Telekommunikationsunternehmens. So möchte ich mal anfangen. Berlin kommt! Und da ging es dann auch um die Frage, wie das dann ist, ob dann in bestimmten Ländern, ob es dann stimmt, dass da die Hotelzimmer verwandt sind und alles Mögliche. Und da berichtete mir einer dann später nicht auf der Veranstaltung, sondern da hat er sich das nicht getraut im Bus nachher zur Abendveranstaltung. Es sei folgendes hätte sich also begeben. Sie seien mit einer Delegation nach Moskau gefahren, um da einen Mobilfunkcarrier zu erwerben. Und da sie sich da nicht auskennen und eben dachten, wie ist das da in Moskau? Hast du da wirklich immer mit Privatleuten zu tun, wenn du eine Firma kaufst? Oder sind das irgendwelche KGB-Fuzzis? Oder ist es das Politbüro oder was auch immer? Haben sie jedenfalls so Leute engagiert von so einem Büro für Sicherheitsfragen, die sich halt in Moskau auskennen in der Szene? Sozusagen als Berater, um da vor Ort irgendwie besser agieren zu können. Und auf dem Weg dahin ist so ein Gespräch eben auch entplant um die Frage, weil die behauptet haben, jedes, also wirklich jedes einzelne Hotelzimmer in Moskau sei aus historischen Gründen verwandt und diese Installation...
Aus historischen Gründen? Wir machen das hier nicht, um irgendwen zu bespitzen.
Und würde halt immer noch benutzt werden, um entsprechend die Funktionäre da mit dem entsprechenden Vorab, Abstimmungen zu versorgen und so fort. Und die von diesem deutschen Unternehmen, die wollten denen das einfach nicht glauben, also jedes ist Quatsch und so weiter und so fort, haben sie halt sich ein bisschen hoch geredet und dann schließlich gewettet, haben halt gesagt, okay, eine richtig Kiste teueren Champagner, wenn du das jetzt nachweisen kannst. Wir fahren jetzt eh gleich ins Hotel, so zeig uns, wo die Dinger sind. Und was sich dann zugetragen hat, wurde dann später ungefähr so geschildert. Also der ist dann halt, der immer behauptet hat, es sei so, ist dann in seinem Zimmer, hat erstmal irgendwie die Spiegel von der Wand gerissen, Dagegut nichts gefunden, dann irgendwie Teppich weggerissen, Bett umgestellt und so fort. Und schließlich, also immer nichts gefunden, aber dann auf dem Fußboden, wo er dann also wirklich das Bett schon weg, den Teppich weggerollt, war dann eine Messingplatte. So irgendwie 20 x 20 cm, fünf dicke Schrauben dran, ist ja irgendwie nochmal in die Tiefgarage, um das Werkzeug zu holen, hat die Schrauben gelöst und als er dann die letzte Schraube löste, hat er irgendwie einen Mords-Krawumm gegeben, wo der Kronleuchter des drunterliegenden Ballsaals von der Decke ging. Zum Glück war da gerade nur die Probe für irgendeinen historischen Tanz. Das sind so viele zu dem Thema Komplexität dieses Themas.
Wer hat denn jetzt hinterher den Champagner gewonnen?
Naja, den hat da irgendwie keiner bekommen. Aber diese Nummer mit dem Kronleuchter, die war wohl echt teuer. Und vor allem, es waren ja eigentlich diskrete, geschäftliche Verhandlungen, wie man da führen wollte. Das war dann auch so ein bisschen für die Füße.
Möglicherweise hat ja der ein oder andere Zuhörende ähnliche Geschichten über Industrie-Spionage, Wirtschaftsspionage zu berichten an der Fritz-Ottoi.
0331 für Potsdam 70 97 110 90 110.
Ich spiele nicht unsere Musik hier.
Ich dachte, du legst ihn mich jetzt hier mal auf den Ausgang?
Du liegst auf den Ausgang. Dein Ausgang liegt ein bisschen...
Ne, sollst du ihn aber auf den Eingang legen, würde ich mal behaupten.
Kollege Dose hat sich mal ein paar Stunden an der Schnellen Leitung verdient gemacht und hat hier zweieinhalb Gigarechte freie Musik zusammengetragen.
Kollege Dose hat das getan? Um dann hinterher rechte beladene Musik draus zu produzieren oder?
Nö, das glaube ich nicht.
Das ist nicht Mittelwelle, das ist eine Apple Soundkarte.
Du mich auch.
Hier ist das Chaosradio 96 mit Wirtschaftsspionage als Thema. Wenn wir Glück haben, ist Volker am Telefon. Volker? Wir haben aber kein Glück und Volker ist nicht am Telefon. Volker ruft doch nochmal an, weil eigentlich würden wir ja ganz gerne unter 0331 77 97 110 der Fritz Hotline Geschichtenshörer von euch und zwar zum Thema Wirtschaftsspionage. Ich hab im Vorfeld ja auch gesagt, das hat doch keiner was zu erzählen. Aber ist gar nicht. Hat eigentlich jeder schon mal gemacht. Also ich hab das auch schon mal gemacht.
Na, das wollen wir jetzt hören.
Ich sag, nee, ach, das war relativ unspektakulär. Ich hab einfach so ein paar. Nee, da kann ich doch jetzt nicht erzählen.
Du bist bei 104.6 reingelaufen und hast mal geguckt, wie du das so machen würdest.
Ich bin bei RS2 rein. Bei RS2 vorbei und hab so getan, als würde mich interessieren, wie du das mit der Qualitätsmusik so hinbekommst. Na ja, und danach hatte ich dann eine Idee, eine Sendung zu machen, die heißt Blumen der musikalischen Verbrechen. Den gibt es immer am letzten Montag im Monat.
Ja, aber ihr habt dafür ja hier die aller tollsten Manuskripte über den Tischen hängen, wenn ich mal vorlesen darf. Geheim Herbstferien-Ausrufezeiten. Thema Autokauf. Ach Mensch, echt das da. Das ist ja schlimm.
Wieso? Warum plusstast du dich denn jetzt so auf? Also was ist schlimm daran?
Na ja, dass ihr hier so die Themen vorgebt, wie damals, kurz vor dem 11. September stand hier in der Ecke immer diese Kiste Musik für besondere Ereignisse oder irgendwie so ähnlich, wo dann irgendwie so ganz emotionalisierende, schöne, traurige Lieder zusammengestellt waren, ohne natürlich politischen Kontext und so fort, dass man gar nichts sagt.
Welches Lied war denn da zum Beispiel dabei?
Welches Lied war denn da?
Jetzt hab ich ihn.
Ja, dann müsste ich jetzt die Bilder raussuchen. Jetzt hab ich ihn. Ja, du mich auch. Aber mal ganz kurz, wir wollten ja über dieses Thema reden. Und vielleicht hilft es ja ein bisschen, historischen Kontext da reinzubringen. Was hat das überhaupt mit dem CTC zu tun? Es gab ja damals in den 80er Jahren diese VEX-Hackerreihen sozusagen. VEX war ein Computer von Digital Equipment Corporation und das Betriebssystem hieß VMS. Das war sehr verbreitet im Wirtschafts- äh Quatsch, Wissenschaftsbereich, im Wirtschaftsbereich vielleicht auch. So beliebt und verbreitet wegen der Komplexität der z.B. Messinstrumente, die man da alle anschließen konnte, um die gemeinsam eine Datenbank zu füttern, dass diese Computer auf den Embargulisten standen, d.h. nicht in den Ostblock verkauft werden durften. Das ist natürlich trotzdem passiert. Das war allen klar, dass man das nicht wirklich verhindern kann. Und sozusagen im Umfeld des CCC kann man sagen, waren diese Computer deswegen sehr beliebt, weil man dafür keine Handbücher brauchte, sondern es gab ein Online-Hilfesystem. Also wahnsinnig bequem. Da kannst du mit dem Computer Englisch sprechen, wenn du da wissen wolltest, wer im System drin ist, sagst du halt Show User, nicht irgendein kudes IBM-Commando, was kein Mensch versteht und so fort.
Vielleicht sollst du noch ihm sagen, von welchem Jahrzehnt wir jetzt hier...
Also wir reden jetzt so vom Jahr 1984 so grob. Und ein Sicherheitsloch, was uns allen damals extrem geholfen hat, war die Möglichkeit, auf die SysURF, die System User Authorization File, zu schreiben, obwohl man das natürlich eigentlich nicht tun können sollte. Das sollte natürlich eigentlich überhaupt keiner tun können, außer das System Operator. Das heißt die Möglichkeit, neue Benutzer da zum Beispiel eingetragen. Wenn man jetzt als unautorisierter Gast im System war zum Beispiel und dann gesagt hat, ich schreib da jetzt mal einen neuen Benutzer rein und der darf alles, hat man natürlich eine Fehlermeldung bekommen, hieß, ey, das darfste nicht. Das Lustige war aber, es ging trotzdem. Also man hat einfach diese Fehlermeldung ignoriert. Man war Fethekanone drin. Und es hat Monate, wenn nicht gar, man kann fast sagen ein Jahr gedauert, bis sich das so weit rumgesprochen hatte, dann auch durch die diversen Vorgänge, dass Digital Equipment dann irgendwann mal reagiert hat, aber hat es auch nur sehr zögerlich und sehr langsam. Und es gibt also verschiedene Papiere jetzt nicht nur von so Spinnern wie wir sozusagen, sondern wirklich aus dem Wissenschaftsbereich, wo halt gemutmaßt wurde, dass dieses Sicherheitsloch im Betriebssystem absichtlich hineingebaut war, um den Zugriff für die amerikanischen Geheimdienste, für die Computer, die es eben trotz Embargo doch in den Osten geschafft hatten, sicherzustellen, dass man eben da eine Hintertür drin hatte, um darauf zuzugreifen.
Aber das ist aber doch, also ich meine, das ist eine Hintertür, die selbst ich gefunden hätte, das kann man doch nicht machen.
Na ja, damals war das ja alles noch ein bisschen anders.
Die haben es ja letztendlich nicht gefunden.
Ja genau, aber ich meine, ja, sie malen sie besser an und so fort. Also vom Grundkontext sozusagen hat sich, kann man fast behaupten, nicht viel geändert.
Na heute hat man einfach gelernt, wie richtige Sicherheitslücken aussehen und da kann man dann eben seine Hintertüren auch so aussehen lassen wie eine Sicherheitslücke. Und daher ist so der Übergang zwischen Hintertür und Sicherheitsloch heutzutage eher fließend. Also man kann dann den Leuten auch nicht wirklich nachweisen, dass es eben absichtlich eingebaut war. Und bei kryptographischen Anwendungen ist es noch viel schwieriger, überhaupt nachzuweisen, dass da ein Problem ist. Also das ist heute alles ein bisschen weniger plump. Aber man lernt ja immer aus der Vergangenheit. Übrigens, viele Geschichten, die wir heute erzählen werden, sind auch echt weit zurück. Und das liegt daran, dass solche Sachen eben auch von den Leuten, die es gemacht haben, geheim gehalten werden. Und man erfährt dann daraus aus den Memoiren von den Leuten. Es gibt auch Fälle, wo Leute gesagt haben, das darf erst publiziert werden, wenn ich tot bin. Das ist ja ansonsten eher so Kissinger-mäßig. Aber jetzt ist die Zeit, wo langsam schöne Geschichten rauskommen. Und wir haben hier ein paar dabei.
Und die Pioniere langsam wegsterben.
Genau.
Ja, aber Wirtschaftsspionage passiert auch durchaus in kleinen. Ich habe neulich von einem Fall gehört, kleine Firma mit einem Kundenverwaltungsdatenbanksystem, das irgendwie gegen die Mitnahme der Kundendaten zur Konkurrenz extra Sicherungsmaßnahmen eingebaut hatte. Nämlich konnte man nicht die ganze Kundenliste ausdrucken, sondern muss jeden Kunden einzeln anklicken und ausdrucken. Dann gab es tatsächlich eine Mitarbeiterin, die hat sich also hingesetzt und sich drei Tage lang jeden einzelnen Kunden angeklickt, ausgedruckt, abgeheftet. Und der Ordner war dann übers Wochenende verschwunden und sie mussten ihr noch eine Abfindung zahlen, als sie sich rauswerfen wollten, weil nachweisen konnte sie es dann wirklich nicht.
Na also aber auch nicht, sie mussten freiwillig, sondern es gab richtig ein Gerichtsverfahren.
Es gab ein Gerichtsverfahren, ja die wollten sie eigentlich fristlos kündigen. Ich meine, wer sowas macht, wer irgendwie die Daten zur, die Listen der Kunden zur Konkurrenz trägt, damit sie bloß noch abtelefonieren müssen, das geht nicht. Aber das nachzuweisen, naja, das kann schwierig werden. Und also es passiert halt auf allen Ebenen. Es passiert bei irgendwie ganz kleinen Firmen, so genannt KMUs, kleine mittelständische Unternehmen.
Das ist eine Abkürzung, die ich erst von einer halben Stunde gelernt habe.
Ja, ja, sowas gibt es wirklich da draußen. Bis hin halt zu großen Firmen. Also ich denke, es ist auch interessant mal einzugucken, wer da Spionage betreibt. Also es sind einerseits die Firmen gegeneinander. Das heißt dann höflicher, das heißt gar nicht Spionage. Das heißt dann in der Regel Marktanalyse oder strategische Konkurrenzanalyse oder im besten Fall Business Intelligence, wobei Business Intelligence schon ziemlich deutlich ist, weil Intelligence ja auch ein englischer Begriff für die Geheimdienstgemeinschaft ist. Und teilweise aber auch Staaten, die gegen andere Staaten, gegen andere Firmen spionieren, um das an eigene Firmen weiterzureichen oder an staatliche weiterzureichen. Also der Kalte Krieg war natürlich ein schönes Beispiel, das reichhaltiges Material bietet. Mittlerweile ist es ein bisschen anders. Mittlerweile ist es alles privatisiert worden.
Soweit das Abstrakte, die konkreten Geschichten, die würden wir gerne von euch hören. Der Fritz Otlein unter 0331 70 97 110 und Axel hat angerufen. Hallo Axel.
Ja hallo, grüß euch. Eine Frage. Ich hab vorhin gehört von den Jungs vom CCC, sie sind in das VMS eingebrochen und haben das URF modifiziert. Da bin ich richtig platt. Vor allen Dingen darüber, dass das in keinem Lockfile mitgeschrieben sein sollte. Das System war, soweit wie ich es kenne, relativ sicher in der Richtung, dass es viele Lockfiles mitschreibt, dass man es zumindest im Nachhinein vollziehen konnte. War das damals wirklich noch nicht so?
Also wir reden ja hier von VMS Version 4.3.4.4 zunächst zu deiner Information. Zum anderen die Sache mit den Lockfiles, für mich liegt es jetzt auch schon eine Runde zurück, aber da gab es auch so ein paranoides Sicherheitsmodul, wo man dann zu jedem Scheiß eine Fehlermeldung auf die Konsole bekam. Wie hieß denn das noch? Hast du das gerade im Kopf? Also da konnte man wunderbare Sachen... Audit. Ja genau. Und das Audit konnte man ja so paranoid einstellen, dass wenn sich jemand nur auf der Tastatur vertippt hat...
Genau, man konnte die Zugriff auf jede Datei protokollieren, wer wann wieso und warum.
Aber die Frage ist ja auch sozusagen, inwieweit das...
Wer natürlich mit der Datenmenge was anfangen kann, ist natürlich richtig.
Nein, die Frage ist ja auch, wer so paranoid war. Also ich meine, das so einzustellen, ganz genau.
Ja, das ist schon wahr. Nein, ich wundere mich eigentlich, dass es geht, wusste ich. Aber ich wusste nicht, dass das unbeobachtet ging. Darüber bin ich also doch total platt. Das passt irgendwie ein bisschen in meine Vorstellung von aktuellen Sicherheitskonzepten. Wir wissen alle, dass das ungemein gefährlich ist, aber trotzdem nehmen wir bei der Telekom einfach Telekom als Passwort oder so.
Es gab auch die Möglichkeit damals noch in einer bestimmten Prozess-ID den Benutzer unsichtbar zu machen, sodass der gar nicht im System war.
Ja, ich weiß.
Also das gehörte schon noch dazu.
Okay, ja, ne, bin ich erstaunt, dass es trotzdem gegangen ist. Ich bin lange Zeit schon auf so einem ganzen Pflaster gewesen. Allerdings erst ab 90. Die andere Sache ist, ich hab die Form S Systeme zu DDR-Zeiten gesehen. Und ich weiß...
Da sind wir noch kriminaal im Thema drin.
Und ich weiß, dass es ein alternatives System gab. Das ist in der Serenade Union entwickelt worden. Und hieß irgendwie System, wir drehen da ja Maschine, war im Endeffekt einer Form S basierendes, sagen wir mal, abgekupfertes System. Allerdings, ob das dieselbe Fehlermennung auch noch hatte, weiß ich nicht. Das kenne ich nur vom Ansehen.
Ob sie die Backdoors mitkopiert haben?
Ich denke mal schon, man hat relativ viel übernommen. Es sah auch nicht sonderlich anders aus. Aber bin ich ganz platt darüber, dass es das überhaupt noch ist.
Jetzt bin ich doch nochmal neugierig. Wir haben gleich Nachrichten müssen uns ein bisschen beeilen. Welches Form S System das war denn offiziell, gab es im Osten nicht. Du musst Schalck-Gollet-Kofsky alle gegen Westteppiche einbrechen.
Alles klar.
Ich erzähl nachher noch was zu einer, aber jetzt haben wir erst mal Nachrichten.
0331 77 97 110 sprechen über Wirtschaftsspionage und die alten Geschichten oder auch die neuen oder zumindest aktuellen Geschichten, die wir mit zu tun haben. 0331 77 97 110 hat auch der Sören angerufen, der wartet bitte die Nachrichten ab.
Wenn Fritz in Brandenburg an der Havel, dann 102, 6.
Eine nach der Elf.
Fritz in Pfund.
Heute Nacht zieht der Regen langsam ab. Die Temperaturen sinken auf 10 bis 7 Grad. Morgen dann Maistheiter und trocken bei 16 bis 19 Grad.
Die Meldungen hat Matthias Kerkoff.
Derak hat nach Einschätzung US-amerikanischer Waffeninspektoren vor der Invasion keine Massenvernichtungswaffen gehabt. Das habe die irakische Führung oder das hat Dame Hussein. Keine konkreten Pläne für die Produktion solcher Waffen gehabt. Das geht aus dem Abschlussbericht des obersten US Waffeninspektor hervor, die am Abend offiziell vor dem Kongress vorgelegt wurde. Die EU Kommission hat Beitrittsverhandlungen mit der Türkei unter Auflagen empfohlen. Im Ausland ist das weitgehend positiv aufgenommen worden. Nach Belinder der Türkei erklärten, ein möglicher EU-Beitritt könne Stabilität und Sicherheit im Südosten Europas bedeuten. Auch die Bundesregierung begrüßte die Entscheidung. Brandenburgs voraussichtlich neue rot-schwarze Koalition ist für eine friedliche Nutzung der Kyrie-Zrupiner Heide. Das erklärten die Landeschefs von SPD und CDU, Platzig und Schönbohm, nach ihren fünften Koalitionsverhandlungen. Morgen wollen beide Parteien über die Verteilung der Ministerien und über Personalfragen beraten. In Berlin werden die Preise für Trink- und Abwasser zum 1. Januar 2005 um durchschnittlich rund 5% angehoben. Das beschloss der Aufsichtsrat der Berliner Wasserbetriebe. Der Verkehr Fritz vom ABB Verkehrsflieger und der Fritz-Motorrad-Staffel derzeit keine Meldungen, gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank, Matthias. 3 Minuten nach Abelf.
Jeden Samstagabend 20 Uhr im Big Eden, in der ehemals größten Entjungferungsanstalt Europas Wasch's Woche, ein Programm, das sich auf die aktuellen Ereignisse der Woche bezieht. Kann man sich so vorstellen, wenn jetzt zum Beispiel in der Woche ein neuer Kontinent auftauchen würde, was jetzt schon längere Zeit nie mehr passiert ist, dann würden wir diese Nachricht erst mal recherchieren. Und dann würden wir uns einen Witz dazu ausdenken, der würde ungefähr so gehen, neuer Kontinent, als wenn es nicht schon genügend gäbe.
Jeden Samstag ab 20 Uhr live im Big Eden am Kuhl am Berlin.
Und im Radio.
Dreiste Musik.
Wir haben die Fortschritte in Saddam International Airport zerstört. Wir haben sie verbreitet, im Fakt haben wir sie zerstört.
Also wer es nicht erkannt hat, das war der irakische Propagandaminister.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Informationsminister.
Entschuldigung.
Mohamed, ich hab nochmal nachgeguckt, sein voller Name lautet Mohamed Saeed Al-Sahaf. Das war der, weswegen, also wegen dem haben wir noch gerne CNN geguckt, oder?
Ja, ja großartig der Mann. Der war groß, vor allem war er auf einmal einfach weg. Das war nicht das Allerbeste.
Das war irgendwann einfach nicht mehr gekommen, ist so im Pressekonferenz.
Ja, schön fand ich wirklich.
The Allied Forces are committing suicide in the desert. Oder was er gesagt hat, sehr schön.
Chaosradio 96, wie sieht was aus?
Ja, Andy? Aus dem Internet. Nach Full Control heißt das Lied von Quincy James versus Comic Adi and the Coalition Crew.
Ich hab mir leider keine bestellt, aber ich hab ja auch keine George W. Bush Figur im Fliegerkostüm.
Da steht leider die URL nicht dabei, aber gut.
Chaosradio 96, Wirtschaftsspionage, unser Thema. 0331 77 97 110, die Nummer der Fritzertlein. Ihr seid auch gefordert anzurufen und eure Wirtschaftsspionage-Geschichten zu erzählen, die gar nicht so groß sein müssen. Mal gucken, was Sören für einen hat. Hallo Sören.
Ich bin, es geht so ein bisschen in die Richtung meines Vorredners, hätt ich bald gesagt. Ich bin gestern im Stadtmuseum in Hildesheim gewesen, da läuft im Moment so eine Ausstellung, nennt sich irgendwie Top Secret und geht um Spionage im weitesten Sinne. Sie haben da Exponate von irgendwelchen alten KGB Techniken und so weiter. Und da haben sie auch ein Exponat. Das geht um Chip-Kopie, also Westchips, die im Osten kopiert wurden. Und irgendein westlicher Hersteller, keine Ahnung wer, stand auch nicht dabei, hatten halt nur das Exponat, die hatten in ihren Chip praktisch eingraviert. In schlechtem Russisch, da war dann halt so eine Ausschnittsvergrößerung von dem Chip auf so einem Foto, stand dann drauf, ja also ihr lieben Leute da im Osten, hört doch auf zu kopieren, ihr habt doch schon genug kopiert.
Und haben sie es mitkopiert?
Das weiß ich nicht. Kenn ich noch nicht. Das entzieht sich dann meiner Kenntnis, aber doch irgendwie ganz witzig, finde ich das.
Ja, also aus der Ecke gibt es ja die tollsten Anekdoten, was die Russen und DDR alles geklaut haben sollen. Also es gibt zum Beispiel eine Geschichte über den Z80 Nachbau namens U...
U880.
U880, das Kernstück des KC85-3. Genau, also...
Der DDR-Homecomputer.
Ach so, ja es gibt Leute, die kennen das nicht. Mehr, noch, also nicht.
Also die sind hier genau richtig, die Leute, denn wir erklären das ausführlich. Jedenfalls, also dieser Prozessor ist kopiert worden, indem man also oben abgeätzt hat und dann hat man das abfotografiert und nachgebaut und damals waren die Strukturen noch nicht so hoch in dem Gerät wie heute. Jedenfalls haben sie dann eine Leiterbahn weggelassen beim ersten Versuch, weil die überflüssig aussah und es stellte sich dann später raus, dass das ein Kondensator war und dass deswegen die Kopie initial nicht funktionierte. Also das lässt dann doch tief blicken über die Fähigkeiten der Leute, die das kopiert haben. Das waren also nicht unbedingt Prozessor-Spezialisten. Ansonsten habe ich noch eine kleine Anekdote zu der WEX.
Bevor wir Sörens Gebühren urticken lassen, war es das schon Sören? Ach je, dafür haben wir dich zu lange warten lassen, nichts für ungut. 0331 77 97 110 für alle anderen, die auch lange warten wollen, um dann eine kurze Geschichte aus der Welt der Wirtschaftsspionage zu erzählen.
Genau. Also einer der Konkurrenten von Digital Equipment Corporation, die die WEX gebaut haben, war Control Data. Und man erzählt sich, also das geht aus einem Buch hervor, was auch eine Biografie ist von den ganzen Computerpionieren aus der Zeit. In dem Buch heißt es jedenfalls, dass der Obertechie von Control Data rübergelaufen sein soll zu Digital und die haben damals in einer Scheune in Massachusetts gehaust, haben sie ihr Hauptquartier gehabt. Und der hat sich halt einen Blaumann angezogen und ist da reingelaufen und hat festgestellt, da war schon Adelaide Blaumann und hat dann gewartet, bis der fertig ist. Der hat da halt rumgewerkelt an der einen VEX und also die Control Data Leute haben sich natürlich Sorgen gemacht, weil die VEX war also bahnbrechend technisch gesehen damals und die wollten also sehen, wie fortschrittlich ist das wirklich und wie teuer ist das so für Material, so was zu bauen. Und haben also dann diesen Typ, der ist da halt hingegangen im Blaumann, hat sich da hingestellt und hat das Ding eben dann auch aufgemacht und hat da also den Tag ungefähr dran rumgeschraubt, hat das alles schön auseinandergenommen, abfotografiert und ist dann halt nach Hause gegangen, am Ende. Und ist also kein Mensch hat irgendeine Frage gestellt.
Gut, wir hören wieder einen Anrufer. 0331 77 97 110, das ist der Enno.
Ja, meine Geschichte ist eigentlich die, dass es in einer deutschen Universität, in der ich mal eine Weile zu tun hatte, also nicht direkt in der Universität, sondern in einem Institut dazu, natürlich auch diverse Leute gab, die da irgendwelche Diplomarbeiten oder ähnliches gemacht haben. Dieses Institut wurde von einem großen deutschen Industriekonzern, sagen wir mal, teilweise gesponsert. Aber da lagen eigentlich sehr viele Mehrgeräte vom Hauptkonkurrenten rum und die mit sehr vielen Drähten und technischen Geräten dran und wurden da irgendwie gerne mal näher angeguckt.
Auch sowas gibt es ja. Das ist auch eine nette Geschichte. Ist das in Berlin?
Nee, das war eher weiter westlich.
Einzelne wollen ja hier niemanden konfrontieren.
Weil die Leute aus unserem Clubumfeld dort immer noch tätig sind.
Ja, das sollten wir dazu sagen. Das haben wir in der Ankündigungs-Sendung geschrieben. Also wir erwarten nicht, dass ihr jetzt hier Namen nennt oder so. Sondern wir sind eigentlich eher an den Geschichten interessiert. Also Holger ist doch nicht gemeldet, aber...
Ross und Reiter müssen hier mal genannt werden.
Bevor ihr gar nicht anruft, ruft lieber an und sagt dann die Namen.
Zum Thema Ross und Reiter hätte ich ja sonst noch einen Song, aber okay. Was?
Mehr war es auch gar nicht. 0371 77 97 170.
Ich wollte dich nicht bei der Telefonnummer unterbrechen.
Hast du ja auch nicht.
Gut. Eine Geschichte, die kleine Anekdote, eine Firma, für die ich auch mal kurze Zeit tätig war, die auch mal jemanden hatte, der da geputzt hat, von dem ich dann hinterher herausstellte, dass er zwei Doktoren hatte, also zwei Doktortitel. Und naja, also wieso der es nötig hatte, nachts zu putzen?
Das erinnert mich an die, ja, das gibt es auch in diesen Wirtschaftsspionagekonferenzen. Gibt es dann verschiedene Methoden, wie man die Leute erkennt. Und Überqualifizierung ist natürlich total gefährlich. Ebenso wie, da gibt es irgendwie noch so verschiedene Tiergeschichten, wo man irgendwie sagt, der Geier und der Speer und was weiß ich was. Aber am besten waren noch die Sachen mit den bestgesicherten Geheimnissen der Firma, die man gar nicht aus den Computern holt, auch nicht in die Büros einbricht, sondern man setzt sich einfach ein Flugzeug in die Sitzreihe hinter, wo die Chefs sitzen irgendwie und liest einfach mit. Und das gibt es auch.
Das ist ein bisschen unbequem, weil dann ständig einer...
Bei Air Force soll es ja zu gewesen sein, wird heute berichtet in diesem Buch, was jetzt gerade erschienen ist, wo sich man darüber auslässt, dass die Franzosen von den Amerikanern wiederum auch ausgespielt worden seien, während sie in der ersten Klasse in den Flügen also offenbar komplett verwandte Sitze gehabt hätten, in den Kopfstützen und Agenten als erste Klasse Personal.
Also, Herr Franz hat es natürlich sofort dementiert, aber es gibt...
Ja, weil sonst würden sie auch für das schlechte Essen verantwortlich gemacht werden. Da müssen sie natürlich dementieren.
Das wäre aber eine Erklärung für das Essen, ne? Gut, also Herr Franz, das ist üblich so, dass die Firmen das selbst natürlich dementieren, aber wie schon sagte, über Memoiren kommt sowas dann raus. In diesem Fall waren es die Memoiren von dem damals zuständigen Geheimdienstchef der Franzosen. Das heißt schon jemand, der also in der Position ist, das dann auch aus erster Hand beurteilen zu können. Und der hat sich in einem Interview mit CBS Jahre später auch damit gebrüstet, eine 20-Mann-Abteilung eingerichtet zu haben für Industriespionage. Also das ist durchaus üblich. Bei manchen Ländern steht sogar eine offizielle Begründung für Geheimdienste.
Holger, ist das eigentlich für ein Klappern hier?
Ich hab nicht die leisteste Ahnung, dass das für ein Klappern ist, aber warum klappert das eigentlich nicht, wenn ich dir ein Zeichen gebe, dass dann Musik kommt?
Achso, weil ich diese Musik nicht als Hintergrundmusik geplant hatte.
Ist klar, aber der Pfefe war ja fertig gewesen.
Na ja, er war noch nicht... Doch, doch. Okay, also das liegt vielleicht am fehlenden Handcheck.
Mach doch mal Musik will er sagen.
Ich tue jetzt mal diese Taste und Holger hört mal auf zu lachen und dreht diesen Regen da mal hoch.
Kann man sie hier irgendwie leise drüben, was hier rauskommt?
Ja und zwar da, wo es reingeht, da wo der Stecker, das Kopfhörers rein, da ist ein Lautsteigeregel. Was hörst du mich? Kannst du mich hören? Ja, ich höre nicht. So, ich gehe mal davon aus, dass alle anderen mich auch hören können. Hier ist Chaosradio 96 und das Thema ist Wirtschaftsspionage heute Abend. Ich habe ja auch ein Make-Up.
Ja gut, aber um jetzt den historischen Bezug nochmal zu erweitern, die andere Geschichte, die es sozusagen gibt, die auch immer noch als Lehrbuchbeispiel, weil auf Steuergeldbasis finanziell gilt, ist natürlich, was 1996 der Europäischen Union passiert ist. Damals waren die Abstimmungen mit den Amerikanern mit Zug auf das GATT, das General Agreement on Trade and Terrorism, das ist so das Handelsabkommen EU-USA. Und während der Verhandlung mit den Amis kamen EU-intern der Verdacht auf, dass die EU-intern abgestimmten Positionen denen irgendwie zur Kenntnis gelangt sind. Und dann hat man damals schon die Büros nach Wanzen abgesucht, wo man das neulich da beim UN-Sicherheitsrat welche gefunden hat. Es war sozusagen sogar dasselbe Gebäude, aber damals hat man keine gefunden. Man hat dann die Mitarbeiter irgendwie zu Einzelverhören geladen, die Sekretärin irgendwie die Schreibtische durchblüht und so fort auf der Suche nach jetzt dem Informations-Lag. Und dann hat man, und das kam dann auch als Veröffentlichung raus in der Sunday Times, allerdings nur in ein, zwei Artikeln, dass also sich amerikanische Regierungshacker sozusagen oder Hacker im Auftakt US-Regierung, wie auch immer, durch die Firewall hindurch den Mail-Server vorgenommen hätten und den also komplett sich runtergelutscht hätten. Nun muss man sagen, zum damaligen Zeitpunkt war die komplette EU-interne Mail-Installation noch von einem großen amerikanischen Outsourcing-Dienstleister betrieben, zum einen. Und zum anderen waren das natürlich US-Produkte, die da eingesetzt waren. Das heißt, diese ganze Geschichte der Kryptoreglementierung ist da auch noch mal andersrum zu sehen, nämlich dass man Unternehmen ja natürlich vorwerfen kann, wenn sie irgendwie Krempl in ihre Systeme einbauen, weil sie schlecht programmieren, aber wenn sie Krempl da einbauen, weil sie sich an die Gesetze ihres Landes halten müssen, dann ist das natürlich schwerlich denen vorzuwerfen, sondern da geht es im Grunde um die Frage, wie transparent diese Sachen sind und deswegen diese EU-Geschichte. Also es gab da ein Zusammenspiel verschiedener Systeme, aber letztendlich ist relativ klar, dass die Hersteller das nicht freiwillig gemacht haben, sondern eben aufgrund von Exportrestriktionen der US-Regierung, die es bis heute gibt. Also deswegen ist auch ein bisschen der Bezug sozusagen kontinuierlich immer noch da zu dieser Art von Sachen.
Also bevor wir jetzt der Europäischen Union vorwerfen, dass sie Microsoft Exchange einsetzt, sollte man vielleicht sagen, auch die NATO hat über mehrere Jahre Exchange eingesetzt. Und heute sieht man das nur nicht mehr, weil sie da einen Vienz-Scanner vorhaben.
Ja, das war ja nicht Exchange damals. Das war ja irgendwie eine Cisco Firewall mit einer... Was war denn das noch? Na gut, den kenne ich nicht.
Ich saß, ich glaube, 2 oder 3 Jahre später mal bei der Europäischen Kommission im Vortragssaal. Das muss man sich vorstellen so wie... Ich glaube, es waren 1000 Sitzplätze, ringsum 12 Übersetzerkabinen für jede Landessprache eine. Da hatte man vor, sich so einen dicken Schalter zu drehen. Da war eine Ethernet-Dose und ich dachte mir, hm, ist eh langweilig in den nächsten zwei Stunden, weil das interessante Thema kam erst später. Gehe ich mal ein bisschen Mail lesen, habe ich meinen Laptop reingesteckt. Ich habe den Weg nach draußen nicht gefunden. Sie haben es offensichtlich nach der Aktion relativ dicht gemacht. Dafür habe ich eine Menge andere interessante Dokumente gefunden. Da habe ich mich natürlich auch gefragt, wer dir da sonst noch alles rausgetragen hat. Es ging um irgendwelche Projektionen von Ölverkäufen. Ich habe es mir dann nicht im Detail angeguckt. Eigentlich wollte ich bloß meine Mail lesen, aber...
Ich hätte gerne die Daten, die du da...
Kannst du haben.
Die hat er doch noch als bietender auf eBay verzeihet, oder? Nein, nein.
Würden wir nie machen sowas.
Ähnliche Geschichten würden wir gern von euch am Telefon hören unter 0331 70 97 110. Denn das hier ist das Chaosradio und da sollt ihr anrufen, wenn ihr was zu erzählen habt jedenfalls. Fefe, du siehst so aus, als würdest du hier gerne anrufen wollen. Das musst du nicht.
Ich wollte gerade mein Handy holen.
Mach mal. Ja, sonst kann ich ja hier noch mal auf diese Taste drücken. Ja, vielleicht kommt dann ja später irgendwann für sie. Genau. Das kommt vorher.
Sag mal, dass mit dieser Taste... Ich war der Selbstläufer bei Apple.
Also man muss dazu sagen, dass... Der Andi die letzte Nacht nicht geschlafen hat, dementsprechend groß ist die Verzögerung zwischen dem tatsächlichen Betätigungstast...
Aber ich glaube, Holger dreht da irgendwie am Riech... .die Entscheidungspelung.
Du kannst hier den Regler unten...
Es ist nicht wirklich frische Musik, wie die Video mir da noch erklären wird.
Ich bin ein bisschen zu Hause.
Ja, dieser Song, der hieß gerade Telefon Tel Aviv, das führt mich gleich zum nächsten Stichwort. Telefon Tel Aviv, zumindest hab ich einen E, hast du recht, hab ich in eine falsche Kategorie geguckt. Steht dabei Artist tatsächlich. Zum Thema Telefon Tel Aviv gibt es allerdings eine ganz andere Geschichte, die im Moment noch auch in der Großindustrie diskutiert wird unter dem Spionageaspekt. Es gibt da ein israelisches Unternehmen, das mit einem erstaunlichen Marktanteil von über 85 Prozent im Moment Telekommunikationsdatensätze verarbeitet. Also konkret geht es um die Firma M-Docs. Was die machen ist für die Carrier, also für die Betreiber von Telekommunikationsnetzen, die Rechnungsstellung sozusagen erleichtern. Rechnungsstellung macht man vollends. Man nimmt die Datenbank sozusagen aller Gespräche, also wer mit wem wann telefoniert hat. Und als nächstes dann die Datenbank der Tarife. Da gibt es herzig Modelle, zu welchen Tagesurzeiten, welcher Kunde welchen Tarif geführt hat und so fort. Und aus diesen Datensätzen rechnet man dann sozusagen das, was ihr am Ende des Monats von einem Konto abgezogen bekommt. Oder dahin überweist, wie auch immer. Und die M-Docs haben wie gesagt einen hohen Marktanteil. Die haben sich auch deswegen am Markt natürlich durchgesetzt, weil sie besonders günstige Konditionen bieten können. Und nachgewiesen ist, dass sie 50 Prozent Wirtschaftsförderung in ihrem Research and Development vom israelischen Wirtschaftsministerium bekommen haben. Nun ist es nicht in allen Ländern, aber in einigen so, dass sie die Daten eben ganz besonders günstig in Tel Aviv rechnen. Und es kommt also bei verschiedenen Carriern, das wurde auch verschiedenlich ausgesprochen, aber in Deutschland redet man natürlich ganz ungern darüber, weil israelisches Unternehmen und wissen schon, ob das sich sozusagen hier gerade so abgespielt hat, dass der Mossad also beschlossen hat, er muss jetzt mal über auf dem Planeten wissen, wer mit wem telefoniert. Und dann finanziert man einfach ein bisschen so eine Firma mit, die dann günstiger als alle anderen am Markt ist. Und da die alle auf ihren Aktienkurs schielen, holen die sich natürlich den günstigsten Anbieter für so eine Lösung entdecken.
Wenn du sagst, dass sie mit 85 Prozent Marktanteil arbeiten, über welchen Markt redest du da?
Weltmarkt. Also kannst du auf M-Docs kommen gehen. Die Kunden, also alle deutsche Mobilfunk-Unternehmen, beispielsweise, lassen bei M-Docs rechnen. Nein, E-Plus auch.
E-Plus auch?
E-Plus macht die ICMR sogar da. Also auf guter Art und Weise der Kundenverwaltung, damit sie feststellen, ob du ein guter Kunde bist, ein A-Kunde oder ein B-Kunde, ob du deine Rechnung regelmäßig zahlst, ob du regelmäßig Ruhe umsetzt hast und so fort. Das sind alles Datenbanken, die automatisch dein Verhalten analysieren, dein Zahlungsverhalten, um dich eben zu kategorisieren, damit dir dann irgendwie ein neues Telefon gemacht wird oder noch ein Vertrag aufgeschwatzt wird oder was auch immer. Diese ganzen Sachen machen ja Lufthansa und Ähnliches auch mit ihren Püfligern und sonst was Programm.
Du weißt doch immer um um, lass uns mal sagen, wie die Sendung heißt. Chaosradio 96. Und Wirtschaftsspionage ist das Thema heute abends. Und ihr seid aufgefordert anzurufen unter 0331 70 97 110 und eure Wirtschaftsspionage-Geschichten zu erzählen. Ich unterbrach dich in dem.
Ja, okay, also das war jetzt auch schon fast die Geschichte von M-Docs rausgekommen oder ins Gerede gekommen ist die Firma M-Docs allerdings in einem ganz anderen Kontext. Nämlich weil es ein anderes israelisches Unternehmen gibt, was auch 50 Prozent selber Art von Förderung bekommen hat. Und das ist eine Firma, die sich deswegen umbenennen musste. Vorher hießen die mal Converse Infosys, heißen sie, nee, nee, warte mal, wie heißen sie denn jetzt? Nee, Variant. Variant hießen sie vorher und jetzt heißen sie Converse Infosys. Und was die machen, ist Lawful Interception Lösungen anliefern. Das heißt, wie die Strafverfolgungsbehörden die Technik die zum Abhören von Telefongesprächen. Nach dem 11. September gab es in Amerika so eine komische Geschichte, dass die US, also das FBI, auf der Bundespolizei dort eine Gruppe von arabischstämmigen Kunststudenten im Verdacht hatte, der Al-Qa'i dazu zu gehören. Das waren so 120 Leute, die man dann über mehrere Monate abgehört hat, um eben festzustellen, ob sie mit was weiß ich, Onkel Bin Laden, telefonieren oder wie auch immer. Und dann hat man eben nach ein paar Monaten beschlossen, die jetzt alle mal zu verhaften und irgendwie in Einzelverhören sich die noch mal anzugucken. Und von den 120 Leuten haben ungefähr 95 am Vortag der geplanten Verhaftung alle spontanen Urlaub in Tel Aviv genommen und sind ausgeflogen. Sodass beim FBI eben der Verdacht aufkam, dass die irgendwie gewarnt waren. Und dann hat man also festgestellt, dass die Lofl Interception Lösung, die man gewählt hatte, um diese Leute abzuhören, eben auch von der israelischen Technologiefirma kam, die offenbar dem Mossad auch noch die Information irgendwie zuliegte.
Eine großzügig bemessene Wartungsschnittstelle.
Ja, genau so. Richtig. So nennt man das ja auch bei M-Docs, auch die andere Parallele.
Welche von den Firmen waren das vielleicht, die sich haben erwischen lassen, als sie eine Hintertür ins Telefonsystem des Weißen Hauses eingebaut haben?
Warte mal kurz, das waren diese anderen. Und zwar... Moment. Ah, spür doch noch mal einer Musik, denn fällt sie mir gleich wieder ein. Die sind aber immer noch offen. Da muss ich jetzt mal rumklicken. Also wenn meine Daten mag mir nicht belugt, war das Avaya. Avaya ist eine Tochter von Lucent, also ein Spin-off von Lucent. Lucent entwickelt ja Technik, Avaya betreibt dann die Netze. Das Billing machte verständlich M-Docs, die laufen in der Sepschen-Krempel, kommen von Werbin, also da haste sie alle als Familie aufgestellt.
Also es gab in der Aktion auch am Ende einen Zeitpunkt, wo ich glaube 30 Israelis wegen Spionageverdacht ausgewiesen wurden aus den USA, was kurz in den Nachrichten war und dann ganz schnell verschwunden ist und das war der Auslöser dafür, dass sich diese eine Firma umbenannt hat.
Ja und was man dazu noch sagen muss, es gibt jetzt in den USA auch ein Gesetz, also eine FCC-Richtlinie, was den amerikanischen Behörden verbietet, ausländische Anbieter in den Ausschreibungen überhaupt zu berücksichtigen, wenn sie sowas wie Loffel in der sächsischen Technologie anbieten. Also da wird nur noch indienisches Zeug gekauft, auch wenn sie billiger sind, weil dieses Argument natürlich das lädt ja gerade dazu ein, es braucht es werden. Das interessante ist aber, ich habe diese Geschichte neben anderen Sachen auf der BKA-Tagung letztes Jahr repariert, wo mir dann beim Frühgespräch einige sagten, ja, ja, sie hätten ja auch schon über geredet, auf Bundesebene sei das aber bekannt. Aber Berlin beispielsweise hat auch Converse Infosys Technik gekauft, weil Berlin ist ja pleite und brauchte das Zeug halt und die waren halt billiger. Also so einfach macht man das Hacken heutzutage sozusagen aus Sicht eines Staates offenbar. Wenn man irgendwo Technik reinkriegen will, muss man einfach nur ein bisschen billiger sein als die anderen. Das ist natürlich prima.
Man muss auch sagen, ich finde es ja preisverdächtig, weil das praktisch der Mossad in meinen Augen der einzige Dienst ist, der das Problem gelöst hat, dass Abhören eigentlich teuer ist. Ich meine, das lässt man sich dann abfinanzieren. Ich meine, das ist doch eine Leistung.
Das ist wirklich eine gute Idee. 0331 77 97 110. Eure Geschichten zum Thema Wirtschaftsspionage würden wir gerne hören. Also vielleicht ruft ja Herr Lopez mal hier an und erzählt, wie er seinerzeit die Daten von VW zu Opel geschleppt hat, was Opel ja dann doch nicht so viel genutzt hat. Im Endeffekt 0331 77 97 110 hat Dennis gewählt. Hallo, Dennis.
Und zwar ging es darum, bei mir in der Firma wurde vor ein paar Tagen, vor ein paar Wochen eine rausgeschmissen. Den haben sie erwischt, wir haben in der Digitalkamera rumgelaufen.
Was für eine Firma ist das?
Das ist nicht in deiner Branche.
Das ist nicht uninteressant.
Aber magst du zur Branche was sagen oder lieber nicht?
Na sagen wir mal Pressenbau. Und zwar, wie gesagt, der wurde dabei erwischt, wie er mit der Digitalkamera rumgelaufen ist und fotografiert hat. Jedenfalls wurden daraufhin bei uns in der Firma Foto-Handys verboten. Fotoapparate allgemein. So vor zwei Wochen ist aber dann eine Delegation bei uns in der Firma gewesen, von Polen und Russen. Und die sind jedenfalls mit ihren Kameras in den Mund durch die Firma gelaufen. Super. Also fand ich ziemlich makabe das Ding.
Und habt ihr denn eure Sicherheitsverantwortlichen darauf angesprochen, dass die Policy da offenbar etwas ungleichmäßig enforced wird?
Die Policy wird ungleichmäßig enforced?
Ja, das kann man bestimmt auch noch wie auf Deutsch austritten haben. Okay, also dass die grundsätzlich möglicherweise sinnvolle Regel in unlogischer Art und Weise quatscht.
Und ausgewogener Art und Weise umgesetzt wird.
Nehm mal im Ernst, hast du da Krawall gemacht?
Ne, also ich hab dazu gar nichts gesagt, ich will mich da auch nicht einmüssen.
Snafu-Effekte.
Der was, der Snafu?
Und der Typ, der da umfotografiert hat, den haben sie dann rausgekantet, so fristlos?
War denn nachweisbar, dass der irgendwas sensibles fotografiert hat? Ich meine, vielleicht hat er bloß die Sekretärin fotografiert.
Nee, also der ist schon in der Anlage, wo das alles gebaut wird, umgelaufen. Ich weiß nicht, ob er Pläne direkt fotografiert hat. Er soll jedenfalls gesehen worden sein. Ja, schönen Abend noch.
Danke, grüß dich. 0331 77 97 110 für eure Geschichten. Was für eine Situation war das?
Das NAFU-Prinzip. Das sagt eben, dass die unten Bescheid wissen und je höher man in der Berichterstattung nach oben kommt, in der Hierarchie einer Firma, dass so anders sieht die Meldung aus und unten geht halt die Meldung raus, alles scheiße. Und oben kommt an, wie war das? Es riecht stark und ist gut für die Blumen.
Das ist gut für das Wachsen der Firma.
Das ist gut für das Wachsen der Firma, genau.
Ausführlich haben wir es NAFU, heißt Situation Normal All Fucked Up. Und ist sozusagen die Erklärung, warum Kommunikation nur an der gleichen funktionieren kann oder andersrum warum in Hierarchien Kommunikation überhaupt nicht funktionieren kann, weil jemand, der Macht über Anrat erfährt, aus zwei Gründen nicht die Wahrheit. Die einen wollen sich eben einschmeicheln, weil sie auch höher wollen. Und die anderen, die irgendwas unangenehmes zu berichten haben, die wollen natürlich den Kopf nicht abgeschlagen bekommen und formulieren das deswegen auch etwas netter. Und deswegen entsteht halt da so ein Kommunikations-
Trichter.
Trichter, ja.
Also ich finde das auch nicht ganz negativ, muss ich sagen, was wir gerade gehört haben. Es gibt auch Firmen, die das offensiv betreiben und die sagen, also wenn die Chinesen das dann billiger bauen können, dann kaufen wir das halt da ein. Also das muss nicht schlecht sein. Und man spart sich dann auch die Auswahl des kompetenten Nachbauers auf die Art, weil wer halt durchkommt, gewinnt. Also man kann das auch als progressive Sparmaßnahme begreifen.
Progressive Sparmaßnahme. Stefan hat angerufen. Hallo Stefan.
Ich habe gerade von gehört, dass viel der Name Avaia von dieser amerikanischen Telekommunikationsfirma, die sich von DuSant irgendwie abgetrennt hat, habt ihr gesagt, ne?
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie wirklich abgetrennt sind, aber sie sind auf jeden Fall eine eigene Business Unit.
Ganz interessant, was ich dazu heute gerade gelesen habe, dass dieses Firma dabei ist, ein traditionelles deutsches Telekommunikationsunternehmen gerade aufzukaufen. Das ist die Firma Tenovis.
Tenovis war doch mal Bosch Telekom, ne?
War mal Bosch Telekom, war mal TN, Telefonbau und Normalzeit und so weiter. Das Ding ist eigentlich auch schon über 100 Jahre alt. Also vielleicht ergibt sich da ja auch noch das eine oder andere, wo die ein bisschen neugierig werden könnten.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall der ein Aspekt. Den anderen, der mir jetzt gerade noch wieder einfällt, ist, dass der Chef von M-Docs war neulich in Berlin auf so einer Venture-Kapitalveranstaltung. Und was der gesagt hat, da hat es mir wirklich die Schuhe ausgezogen. Der hat dann so seine Folien präsentiert mit seinen Umsatzzahlen und meinte halt so, ja, wissen Sie, wir haben natürlich auch erkannt, wir haben jetzt ein Problem. Bei 85 Prozent Marktanteilen kann man einfach nicht schrecklich hohe Zuwachszahlen noch erwarten. Und deswegen haben wir uns überlegt, dass wir jetzt mal irgendwie mit der Telekontaktionsbranche, das haben wir jetzt wohl halbwegs in Griff, jetzt machen wir mal Software für Banken. Und du denkst so, oh Scheiße, jetzt geht das erst richtig.
Das interessante dabei ist, dass ich jetzt von einer Bank weiß, die gerade ihre Telefonanlage auf Tenoris umgestellt hat.
Ja gut, klar, das geht zur Sache.
Ich meine, die eine Firma sammelt die Verbindungsdaten, die andere Firma informiert irgendwelche Leute und die dritte Firma baut die Telefonanlage.
Ja, wobei Siemens da nicht so viel besser ist. Also wir können ja mal das Russland-Feature erwähnen. Vielleicht will Andi oder?
Welches Russland?
Erstmal danke Stefan. Erstmal.
Welches Russland-Feature? Meinst du eine Visitenkarte von dem Typen mit der Rückseite oder welches?
Nein, nein, man spricht bei den Telefonanlagen von einem Russland-Feature, weil die Telefonanlagen haben natürlich weltweit dieselbe Software und da schaltet man dann eben für das Land entsprechend die gesetzlichen Regulatorien ein. Und wenn man bei so einer Telefonanlage einstellt, dass man in Russland ist, dann gibt es eben dort Gesetze, die zum Beispiel einen Feature freischalten, dass man anrufen kann und das Telefon nimmt also automatisch ab, ohne zu klingeln. Und so Mitschnittmöglichkeiten und so was. Und so was ist also auch in allen Telefonanlagen drin, die man hier kauft, wenn die auch in Russland verkauft werden. Das ist dann nur in einer Firmware vielleicht nicht angeschaltet.
Weil die Telefonanlagen halt für den Weltmarkt verkauft werden, wie man so schön argumentiert. Und dieses vorhin bereits erwähnte Technikymisterium namens LI oder auch Lawful Interception, also das gesetzmäßige Abhörschnittstellen, das ist natürlich kein einheitlich definiertes Dingens. Weil in vielen Ländern ja die Gesetze nun mal unterschiedlich sind. Und in einigen Ländern ist die Gesetzeslage so, dass das Gesetz im Wesentlichen aus einer Person besteht. Und die sagt dann so, ey mein Leute, denen vertraue ich null. Und abhören will ich die alle. Und auch das ist dann Lawful Interception. Siemens umschreibt das dann ganz höflich in ihren Broschüren mit den Worten ja hoch, flexibel, skalierbar, hoch performant, flexibel, konfigurierbar. Wo du so denkst, oh Scheiße, der Überwachungsstart kommt doch.
Chaosradio 96 auf Fritz ist was ihr hört und Wirtschaftsspionage unser Thema. Ihr seid weiter aufgefordert anzurufen und Geschichten über Wirtschaftsspionage zu erzählen, was ist denn in eurem beruflichen privaten Umfeld passiert. 0331 70 97 110.
Ich meine, das ist ja auch das Tolle am Daten-Liebstahl, die Daten sind ja nicht weg. Die sind ja immer noch da, die sind nur auch noch woanders.
Obwohl umgelagert.
Was heißt umgelagert? Die fehlen ja nicht.
Man erzählt sich Geschichten von dem französischen Geheimdienst, dass sie tatsächlich flächendeckend einbrechen in Hotels und da die Dokumente also nicht einfach kopieren, sondern klauen. Und es gibt also eine besonders peinliche Story, wo es dann hieß, dass am nächsten Tag, also solche Geschichten sind besonders gut dokumentiert in der Flugzeug- und Aerospace-Branche, weil die eben bestimmte Meldepflichten haben. Und da gibt es also mehr Stories als üblich in der Branche. Und hier war es also British Aerospace, die haben halt ein paar Executives nach Frankreich geschickt, die sollten damit Airbus verhandeln. Und am Abend vor den Gesprächen ist also eingebrochen worden in das Hotel und dann waren halt die Memos von denen weg. Und am nächsten Tag sind ihnen die von der französischen Airbus-Delegation zurückgegeben worden mit Entschuldigung. Und das hätten ihnen irgendwelche Government-Officials gegeben. Und in diesen besagten Memoaren von dem Chef des Inland-Geheimdienstes in Frankreich heißt es, dass er also sagt, sie hätten pro Tag ungefähr ein Dutzend Einbrüche. Also schon flächendeckend.
Und der ist da noch stolz drauf.
Der ist da stolz drauf, ja. Ja, es gibt ja Aussagen von der NSA, wobei ich gerade nicht genau weiß, wo das eigentlich herkam, wo es heißt, 40 Prozent von deren Budget seien für Industrie-Spionage und Wirtschafts-Spionage. Heißt einer von euch das nochmal, wo das genau war? Ich glaube, das war auch ein Interview von dem, von dem der CIA-Chef ist.
Im Rahmen dieses Echelonausschusses gab es ja dann verschiedene Versuche, auch von dem Echelonausschuss des Europäischen Parlaments da in Amerika vorstellig zu werden. Und zwei der Termine sind ja kurzfristig abgesagt worden. Das eine war beim Economic Collection Reconnaissance Office oder irgendwie so einen ganz komischen Namen, der schon danach roch. Das ist da irgendwie so ein ganz merkwürdiger Laden, so was ähnliches wie eine Industrie und Handelskammer, aber nur für große Unternehmen, wo dann der amerikanische damalige Innenminister, dessen Name mir jetzt leider gar nicht einverstanden noch hingestellt hat, und gesagt hat, ja ja, natürlich hören wir die Europäer ab, weil die spielen ja nicht fair, die bestechen ja Regierungen und so weiter und so fort. Deswegen müsste man ja das Wirtschaftsgeschehen der Europäer überwachen. Also eine interessante Begründung, die dann sozusagen dann irgendwie übergelegt wird.
Können froh sein, dass die uns nicht die Verteidigung erklärt haben.
Die Verteidigung?
Nicht Verteidigungsminister.
Soll ich dir nochmal den Iraqi Information Minister?
Genau, bitte, können wir das nochmal, oder? Genau.
The Air Committing Suicide in the Desert.
Ja, aber die DVD, die man auf, wo war das gleich?
Amazon, bei Amazon, die kamen für 7, 99 Euro.
Sag mal, wie der Mann heißt, Komik El Ali.
Komik El Ali, und zwar war das Mohammed Said Al-Sayyaf, hieß der. Das war der irakische Informationsminister, der mir diese Pressekonferenzen gegeben hat und dann irgendwann verschwunden war.
Wir haben die Stärken in Saddam International Airport geschlachtet. Wir werden sie alle geschlachtet. Wir haben sie verletzt. Wir haben sie verletzt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du sie alle kennen kannst.
Na Benz, Chaosradio 96 ist hier. Wir reden über Wirtschaftsspionage und hören dabei Musik von Andy Müller-Magun.
Naja, das ist jetzt ja nur irgendwie eine MP3 Collection, die mir der Herr Sven Dose neulich netterweise noch überspielt hat, weil das alles freie Musik ist, die man im Internet so findet, die man sogar legal runterladen darf. Das hier ist ein Lied namens Call Center Worker und dabei fällt mir ein, diese lustige Geschichte. Also vielleicht haben wir ja auch Hörer oder Hörerinnen, die in Call Centern arbeiten. Da erfährt man ja mitunter auch lustige Dinge, über die man dann fast nicht reden darf. Es gab ja beispielsweise dieses Rätselraten, wie dann jetzt die Lufthansa, Senator, Miles and Moore-Flugdaten unserer werten Herren Bundestagsabgeordneten mit diesen Thailand-Flügen auf Bundestagskosten sofort rausgekommen sind. Das war ja offenbar eine Call-Center-Mitarbeiterin, die den Zugriff auf diese Daten hatte und es dann systematisch rausgesucht hat und Fokus oder Locos oder irgendein Magazin verkauft hat. Aber blöderweise hatten die Logfiles, wo sie genau feststellen konnten, wer dann auf diese Daten zugegriffen hat. Die mussten nur mehrere Terabyte Log-Dateien durchgehen. Und deswegen hat das vier Wochen gedauert, bis man die Frau dann rausgeworfen hat.
Aber da ist die Frau, die aufgedeckt hat, das, ne?
Das, ja, gut.
Davon kann sich jetzt, glaub ich, auch nichts mehr kaufen.
Das ist richtig, aber ja, ja, ja, in den Spiegel gucken morgens.
Das ist auch was, wer das...
Das ist übrigens eine interessante Fragestellung. Also in den USA gibt es sogenannte Whistleblower Gesetze. Genau, und die Gesetze sagen also, dass eine Firma einen Mitarbeiter nicht dafür bestrafen darf, dass er der Presse gegenüber auspackt. Das Problem ist, dass...
Wenn was illegales passiert?
Auch so, also wenn er jetzt Firmengeheimnisse der Presse übergibt, das ist... Ist es nicht ein Firmengeheimnis? Es geht darum, wenn der Mitarbeiter beobachtet, dass die Firma irgendwas tut, was sie nicht tun sollte. Und das der Presse mitteilt, dann darf er dafür von der Firma nicht belangt werden. Das gilt auch für Behörden. Und da gibt es aber jetzt Geschichten inzwischen, dass die US-Regierung da einen Weg drum rumgefunden hat, der ganz interessant ist. Und zwar ist es so, dass die den Leuten dann zwar, die feuern sie nicht, aber sie nehmen ihnen die Clearance weg. Das heißt, die dürfen zwar noch arbeiten, aber dürfen die Räume nicht betreten, in denen sie arbeiten dürfen. Weil da braucht man Security Clearance 5 und die haben halt nur 4. Und so werden die dann halt doch gefeuert. Das heißt, so eine Gesetze, da kann man auf der einen Seite sagen, wieso haben die das und wir nicht? Und auf der anderen Seite kann man sagen, ja funktioniert doch nicht.
Weißt, ist schon das nächste.
Das war der DJ Killer.
Nee, du hast da etwas zu schnell diesen Regler da.
Nee, hier ist nicht, mein Regler ist das nicht. Du hast die Musik ausgemacht. Doch, doch, doch.
Der Song war der letzte. Das ist eine Technik-Sendung. Das ist schon peinlich irgendwo.
Wenn Fritz in Stiegels und Wilmersdorf, dann 102, 6.
Eine Nache zwölf.
Fritz Info.
Mit dem Wetter nachts zieht der Regen langsam ab. Die Temperaturen sinken auf 10 bis 7 Grad. Morgen ist es meist heiter und trocken bei 16 bis 19 Grad. Und die Meldungen, die gibt es von Matthias Kerkhoff.
Der Irak hatte nach Einschätzung US-amerikanischer Waffeninspektoren vor der Invasion keine Massen Vernichtungswaffen. Auch habe die irakische Führung und das Adam Hussein keine konkreten Pläne für die Produktion solcher Waffen gehabt. Dies geht aus dem Abschlussbericht des obersten US Waffeninspektör hervor, der am Abend offiziell dem Kongress vorgelegt wurde. Die EU-Kommission hat Beitrittsverhandlungen mit der Türkei unter Auflagen empfohlen. Im Ausland ist das weitgehend positiv aufgenommen worden. Nachbarländer der Türkei erklärten, ein möglicher EU-Beitritt könne Stabilität und Sicherheit im Südosten Europas bedeuten. Auch die Bundesregierung begrüßte die Entscheidung. Brandenburgs voraussichtlich neue rot-schwarze Koalition ist für eine friedliche Nutzung der Küre zur Pinerheide. Das erklärten die Landeschefs von SPD und CDU Platzik und Schönboom nach ihren fünften Koalitionsverhandlungen. Morgen wollen beide Parteien über die Verteilung der Ministerien und über Personalfragen beraten. In Berlin werden die Preise für Trink- und Abwasser zum 1. Januar 2005 um durchschnittlich rund 5 Prozent angehoben. Das beschloss der Aufsichtsrat der Berliner Wasserbetriebe. Der Verkehr auf Ritz mit Schwerneustransporten auf der A13 Schönefelder Kreuz Richtung Dresden zwischen Schönefelder Kreuz und dem Dreieck Spreewald fährt ein Schwerlasttransport überholen nicht möglich. Und auf der A13 Dresden Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz zwischen Ruhland und Schönefelder Kreuz fahren sechs Schwerlasttransporte. Auch hier ist ein Überholen nicht möglich. Sechs? Sechs.
Drei Minuten nach halb zwölf. Wir machen keine halben Sachen. Drei Minuten nach halb zwölf. Vielen Dank, Matthias Karghoff.
Fritz präsentiert Silbermond.
Bitte warten Sie.
Bitte haben Sie noch etwas Geduld. Es wartet noch eine Person vor Ihnen.
Bitte haben Sie noch etwas Geduld. Es wartet noch eine Person vor Ihnen. Bitte warten Sie. Bitte haben Sie noch etwas Geduld. Es wartet noch eine Person vor Ihnen. Bitte haben Sie noch etwas Geduld. Es wartet noch eine Person vor Ihnen. Bitte haben Sie noch etwas Geduld. Es wartet noch eine Person vor Ihnen.
Bitte warten Sie. Vielen Dank, dass Sie Chaosradio 96 angerufen haben. Was können Sie für uns tun? 0331 697 110. Was ihr für uns tun könnt ist, uns Geschichten, eure Geschichten zum Thema Wirtschaftsspionage erzählen und bis ihr hier anruft unter 0331 797 110, erzählen wir unsere Geschichten über Wirtschaftsspionage bzw. erzählen die ihre Geschichten über Wirtschaftsspionage, denn ich weiß keine die. Das sind Fefe, das sind Andreas und Andi. Ja, damit ihr jetzt bitte auch nicht...
Wir haben so die zwei bekanntesten noch gar nicht erzählt. Also wenn man so in der Mainstream Presse oder in irgendwelchen, weiß ich, billig Sat1 berichten über das Thema, werden eigentlich nur zwei Fälle erwähnt. Und der erste ist, dass ein ICE-Kauf von Südkorea viel geschlagen ist. Das war 1992. Und das lief also überraschend so ab, dass Tigevé, ein französisches Konsortium, in letzter Minute unterboten hat. Und die landläufige Theorie, wo es meines Erachtens keine Beweise oder Zugaben für gibt, ist, dass ein Fax abgefangen wurde von Siemens intern. Wo also der Preis dann drin stand, den sie bieten würden. Und dass der also weitergegeben sein soll an das Tigevé-Konsortium. Ja, und dass die ihn dann so unterbieten konnten.
Was ist denn mit China? Ich meine, die Deutschen waren sich doch auch relativ sicher, dass der ICE gekauft wird. Und das ist jetzt auch nicht passiert, oder?
Nee, den Transrapid wollten die kaufen, wahrscheinlich.
Transrapid. Und den haben sie ja nicht genommen. Und dann haben sie sich aber noch gedacht, den ICE, den haben wir ja auch noch im Rennen. Und jetzt haben sie doch auch einen Tigevé genommen, hab ich ja kürzlich gelesen.
Das kann sein, ehrlich gesagt. Also China ist eher bekannt aus den ganzen kleineren Gebieten. Da gibt es also lauter Anekdoten.
Es gibt Unternehmen, die untersagen ihren Mitarbeitern, tatsächlich ihre Laptops mit nach China zu nehmen, beziehungsweise ihre unverschüsseten Festplatten, weil es offenbar eine Zeit lang so war, dass bei der Einreise nach China die Leute bei der Röntgenkontrolle im Handgepäck, mit ihren Laptops noch mal kurz durchlaufen und so fort. Es gibt so kleine Festplattenkopierer, das ist echt eine ganz fiese Technologie, die mit extremen Datenraten hier mal kurz die komplette Festplatte kopieren, und das im Handtaschenformat. Es soll wohl tatsächlich eine Zeit lang so gewesen, dass es regelmäßig jede Festplatte einfach mal abgezogen haben, um sich in aller Ruhe die anzugucken.
Das berichtet man aber auch über Israel, wobei die haben insofern einfacher, als dass die länglichen Grenzkontrollen mehr Zeit als China bieten.
Ich weiß nicht, ist das bei den Israel auch bei der Eimrad?
Welchen Vorteil haben die denn davon, dass Israel nicht so viel spioniert? Dem geht es auch nicht besser.
Naja, also besser, ob es denen besser geht, gut. Aber die sind ja nun in einem Spannungsfeld, wo man irgendwie, also ich meine, da ist ja permanenter Ausnahmezustand, mehr oder minder, und ich meine klar, man kann das Normalität nennen, und ich finde ja auch diesen israelischen Witz, den mir ein israelischer Kollege von mir erzählt hat, so schön, weil er meinte, irgendwie kommt Israel, er quatscht, kommt ein palästinensischer Selbstmordattentäter in ein israelisches Restaurant und fragt da ober ihm, möchten Sie was essen? Und der Palästinens sagt so, ne danke, ich platze gleich. Das ist natürlich, ja, das ist nicht, aber nein, also ich glaube, dass die Situation schon ein bisschen unterschiedlich ist. Wenn wir also von Wirtschaftsspionage reden, dann muss man sagen, haben die Chinesen natürlich eine Sache, die wird weltweit anerkannt, nämlich die haben es wirklich raus, Technik zu kopieren, also einfach mal die Produktionskapazitäten in hohen Stückzahlen in die Sachen nachzubauen. Und man muss auch einfach sagen, die haben eins nicht, und das ist Personalmangel. Also die können ja wirklich da einfach mal 20, 30, 40 Ingenieure auf ein kleines Problem nehmen. In dem Kontext mit Israel und Palästina und so fort, das ist ja eine ganz andere Nummer. Da geht es eigentlich auch nicht um Wirtschaftsspionage, sondern da geht es knallhart um politische Interessen.
Das geht schon auch um Wirtschaftsspionage.
Also vorwiegend geht es ja eigentlich um die Frage, wer da welche Atomoppen hat und wer irgendwie Lust hat, den Staat Israel oder alternativ die Araber ins Meer zu kippen.
Na sagt das mal nicht. Also Israel ist wirtschaftlich nicht so stark, aber es gibt eben zwei, drei Branchen, wo sie echt Weltklasse haben. Und das sind also erstens diese Abrechnungssysteme, die wir schon hatten. Und dann Firewalls. Also der Weltmarkt für Firewalls ist ein Checkpoint, das kommt aus Israel. Und das Know-how muss ja irgendwo herkommen. Das heißt, das kann schon sein, dass die da durchaus Interesse daran haben, einreisende Cisco-Ingenieure mal eben die Platten zu kopieren.
Ich will nicht sagen, bei Cisco-Ingenieure schlauer als alle anderen Ingenieure.
Nein, aber die haben...
Besonders interessante Sachen.
Bei Cisco sind schon Sachen verloren gegangen, bei Cisco geht mehr verloren, als bei anderen geschaffen wird. Es gibt ganz lustige Anekdoten zu China. Unter anderem gab es mal eine Geschichte, die hat mir jemand im Usernet zugesteckt. Und zwar kann man aus China nicht nur technisches Gerät billig importieren, sondern auch Naturmagneten. Ein Naturmagnet ist halt ein Stein, der magnetisch ist. Für Industrieanwendungen wird so etwas gebraucht, permanentmagneten. Die gibt es dann eben in bestimmte Formen und Durchmesser und Fellstärke, bla. Die Chinesen bestehen darauf, dass bei der Ausreise in den Flugpapieren genauestens drinsteht, die technischen Daten von den Sachen, die da transportiert werden. Und jetzt gab es einen Fall von einer Firma, die hat eben aus Preisgründen in China ihre Naturmagneten gekauft und hat zwei Wochen später von zwei anderen chinesischen Firmen Werbung gekriegt, besonders angeboten für genau die Art von Steinen, die sie da gerade exportiert haben. Die hören nicht nur aus, wenn sie haben, sondern auch sich gegenseitig.
Ich habe kürzlich irgendwo gelesen, dass auch selbst Mercedes-Benz, die da drüben dann irgendwelche Joint Ventures eingehen oder so, sich wundern, dass auf einmal irgendwelche Motorenteile, Karosserie-Teile von irgendwo her auftauchen und originale Kotflügel verbaut werden, die nie Mercedes-Benz hergestellt hat. Die scheren sich auch wohl offensichtlich überhaupt gar nicht um bestehende Verträge oder sowas.
Taiwan ist da besonders interessant. Taiwan, also es gibt ja China und China. Sowohl Taiwan als auch die Volksrepublik China beanspruchen ja für sich, das wahre China zu sein. Und nun war die internationale Gemeinschaft gezwungen, einen der beiden chinesischen Staaten als den chinesischen Staat anzuerkennen. Was dazu führt, dass Taiwan so ein komisches Zwischending ist und unter anderem in der Menge Abkommen nicht mit drin ist. Also die sind, glaube ich, als eines der wenigen Länder nicht Mitglied der WIPO, sondern erst seit sehr, sehr kurzen Mitglied der WIPO, der World Intellectual Property Organization. Das ist so die, in Anführungszeichen, UNO für Urheberrecht und Copyright und Patente und ähnliche Dinge. Und naja, das scheint ein gutes Geschäft zu sein. Also wenn man sich auch die Volkswirtschaft in Asien anguckt, das ist ja so, die Japaner haben es vorgemacht, die Koreaner haben es dann nachgemacht, dass die auch wirtschaftlich so gewachsen sind. Gucken sie sich mal an, wie so ein Videorecorder funktioniert, dann bauen sie ihn nach. Und wenn sie ihn in zehn Jahren nachgebaut haben, dann können sie ihn plötzlich auch besser bauen. Hat in Japan funktioniert? Hat in Südkorea funktioniert? Funktioniert gerade in China?
Ja, also das ist eine wichtige Sache. Man ist vielleicht leicht geneigt zu denken, Leute, die viel kopieren oder die es nötig haben, Sachen von anderen zu spionieren, die können es dann selber nicht. Eine der Firmen, wo immer die größten, so will ich sagen, abwertenden Gerüchte im Umlauf waren, war Samsung aus Südkorea. Da hieß es über Jahrzehnte, die können also nur kopieren und sind ganz schlimme Piraten. Und wenn man heute mal seit ungefähr, weiß ich nicht, sieben Jahren auf die C-Bild-Stände von Samsung geht, da ist also jedes Mal UFO-Technologie. Die haben 1998, war das glaube ich, einen Camcorder gehabt, der auf DVD aufnehmen konnte, wo man bei anderen Leuten heute noch froh ist, wenn man das irgendwo sieht. Das heißt, das ist nicht gesagt, dass die Leute das einfach schlecht können, sondern es kann sein, dass es einfach Teil von der Gesamtstrategie ist, um im Markt den Überblick zu behalten. Ja, also wenn wir von Industrie-Spionage reden, da sind natürlich Assoziationen bei vielen Leuten da mit Wanzen und versteckten Kameras und so weiter. In der Praxis ist das deutlich moderner. Normalerweise passiert irgendwie gar nicht viel. Die tollsten Sachen werden in Mülleimern gefunden. Da gibt es auch eine eigene Extremsport-Artrum, die heißt Dumpster Diving. Dumpster ist Englisch für Mülleimer und Diving ist Tauchen. Das heißt, es gibt eine eigene Klicke von Leuten, die sich zum Ziel gesetzt haben, in den Müll von anderen Leuten rumzuwühlen. Aber die interessanten Sachen, so technisch gesehen, sind natürlich die Wanzen. Und eine der schönsten Wanzen-Geschichten, die ich zumindest kenne, ist eine Wanze. Also eine der schönsten Wanzen-Geschichten ist eine Wanze, die die Russen, den Amerikanern in ihre Botschaft in Moskau gepflanzt haben. Nun ist es ja so, dass man Wanzen findet, indem man zum Beispiel nach Elektro-Geräten sucht, die also Wärme ausstrahlen. Oder man kann den Funk finden, den die Wanzen ausstrahlen. Das ist so was wie ein Metalldetektor, aber für Halbleiter. Also es gibt da die tollsten Detektionsmöglichkeiten und daher ist also die hohe Kunst der Wanzenbaurei, eigentlich eine Wanze zu bauen, die nicht detektierbar ist. Und die ultimative Wanze in der Beziehung war aus Holz und hatte überhaupt keine aktiven Elemente. Man muss sich vorstellen, eine Delegation von irgendwelchen, was war das, Schülern oder irgendwie so Boy Scouts oder so. Jedenfalls russische Kleinkinder haben also eine Statue überreicht, den Botschafter der Amerikaner in Moskau. Und es war so ein großer Adler. Also der Adler ist ja das Wappentier der Vereinigten Staaten und die Amis haben das also geröhnigt und untersucht und Metalldetektor und alles, nichts gefunden, haben das dann aufgestellt. Und also diese Wanze steht heute im CIA Museum oder NSA Museum. Und es stellte sich dann also Jahre später raus, dass diese Wanze einen Hohlraum hatte, der so ausgelegt war, dass wenn man von außen das Haus mit Mikrowellen bestrahlt hat, dass es dann in einer bestimmten Frequenz raus resonierte und man das dann außen abfangen konnte. Das heißt, da war keine Stromversorgung, keinen Funk, kein gar nichts. Und die haben dann halt festgestellt, Jahre später noch, dass immer so ein Lastwagen vorfuhr gelegentlich, der eben das Haus mit Mikrowellen bestrahlt hat.
Entdeckt haben sie es erst, als sie die Krankheitsfälle der Angestellten dieser Botschaft untersucht haben, weil sie viele Leute dauernd Übelkeit hatten.
Das Niveau der Sendung steigt noch mit dir.
Das ist doch nicht wahr, oder?
Nein, das ist kein Scheiß, das kannst du dir angucken. Die steht da.
Wahnsinn. 0331 70 97 110. Wirtschaftsspionage unser Thema und eure Geschichten hätten wir gerne an der Fritz-Hotline erzählt gekriegt. Max? Max?
Ich hab einen Bekannten, der hat mit dem Fundbüro zu tun gehabt, etc. pp.
Also Flughäfen schlagen mich tot.
Und wenn man sich da mal anguckt, was da für ein Scheiß sich über die Jahre zusammensammelt, von wegen irgendwelcher Jagden, mit lustigen kleinen Klebezetteln von wegen, ganz geheim, nicht liegen lassen, nur für den Firmengebrauch.
Ja, da verfindet sich dann halt alles so auf Flughäfen, etc.
Wird das dann eigentlich auch irgendwann versteigert, oder was passiert damit?
Na also, wenn es einen Wert hat, wird es versteigert nach einer Weile. Dokumenten ist mir jetzt persönlich kein Fall bekannt, aber das passiert tatsächlich häufiger. Jetzt vor ein paar Tagen war eine Meldung übers Oktoberfest. Da sind also, also da werden Sachen gefunden, das fasst man nicht. Ja, also so ein Gebiss kann man sich ja noch vorstellen, dass es jemandem ins Bier kippt oder so, und der wird dann rausgetragen. Aber da haben die Leute also Beinprothesen liegen lassen und da ist ein Koffer gefunden worden mit geheimen Staatsdokumenten, streng vertraulich der bayerischen Landesregierung. Da ging es um neue Gesetzesentwürfe, dass also unter anderem beim Oktoberfest liegen gelassen worden. Also diese geheimen Dokumente, das passiert in der Tat alle nase lang. Ja, das ist natürlich Max.
Vielen Dank für diesen Hinweis und gute Nacht noch. 0331 77 91 0. Andreas? Andreas?
Hallo?
Ja? Jetzt bist du im Radio.
Okay. Ja und zwar, ich kann ja nie aus dem Nähkästchen plaudern mit irgendwelchen Vorkommnissen, aber ich habe mich mal rechtlich damit beschäftigt, wie das zu werten ist, Wirtschaftskönig.
Und du bist du Jurist?
Ich bin Jurist. Und es ist zumindest so, ihr habt ja von den Whistle Blowing Fällen geredet, es ist so, man macht sich zumindest nicht strafbar. Und auch das Unternehmen kann nie gegen einen vorgehen, wenn man da aus dem Nähkästchen plaudert. Gegen die Kündigung wird man, also das ist so eine Krauzone, da wird man kaum gegen was machen können. In Deutschland weiß es eben keine Schutzgesetze gibt, aber die auch das Geheimnis als solches, was man dann unter Umständen preisgibt, ist im Gesetz nicht definiert, aber die Gerichte sagen, dass das Unternehmen zumindest ein berechtigtes Geheimhaltungsinteresse haben müsste. Und da sagt man dann gut, wenn es irgendwelche illegalen Sachen war, die dann ausgeplaudert werden, dann spricht man dem Unternehmen zumindest dieses berechtigte Geheimhaltungsinteresse ab. Also da braucht man als Arbeitnehmer keine Angst haben.
Mache ich mich denn als Arbeitnehmer strafbar, wenn ich das nicht melde? Also wenn ich Kenntnisse erhalte von dem?
Das ist auch ein Argument dafür, weshalb man die Strafbarkeit ablehnt, weil ich kann mich unter Umständen strafbar machen, wenn ich daran beteiligt bin. Also wenn das eine Straftat ist, die ich nicht melde, dann gibt es einen bestimmten Katalog von Straftaten, also jetzt nicht für alle gilt das, sondern ist im Strafgesetzwoche aufgeführt, wenn ich die, die, die Straftaten nicht melde, dann mache ich mich schon alleine deshalb strafbar, wenn ich sie geschehen lasse. Aber das gilt nicht für alle Straftaten. Aber wenn ich da irgendwie in dem ganzen Prozess beteiligt bin und jetzt an Entscheidungsprozessen teilnehme, kann ich mich ja schon allein deshalb strafbar machen. Also nie weil ich sie nicht melde, sondern weil ich daran teilnehme. Und deswegen sagt man, wenn ich so nah an dem Verfahren dran bin, dann müsste man ja das Geheimnis auch so verstehen, dass illegale Geheimnisse nicht unter den Geheimnisbegriff fallen. Und deshalb mich wegen des Geheimnisverrats, der es letztlich ist, strafbar machen.
Hat das denn zivilrechtliche Konsequenzen, oder kann man bloß rausgeschmissen werden, wenn man was ausgradert?
Zivilrecht und Strafrecht läuft ganz parallel. Also weil die Norm, die da relevant ist im Zivilrecht, ist letztlich eine Strafenorm, die dann nur als Schutzgesetz ins Zivilrecht reingezogen wird.
Kannst du das mit dem Mülleimer noch kurz bestätigen, dass es nicht verboten ist, ein anderer Leute Müll rumzukramen?
Ich hab jetzt nicht zugehört, was ist da so?
Ja, es ist mir von mehreren Stellen mitgeteilt worden, dass es nicht mehr illegal sei, wenn man in dem Müll von anderen Leuten nach geheimen Dokumenten sucht.
Nee, es darf nie freigegeben sein. Aber wenn die das nie ordentlich geschreddert haben, dann ist es eigentlich kein Problem. Da haben sie sich sozusagen dessen entledigt und damit ist ihr Geheimhaltungsinteresse damit nicht mehr manifestiert.
Gibt es denn da in dem Kontext auch den Begriff der Fahrlässigkeit, wenn jetzt beispielsweise ein Unternehmen unverschlüsselt per E-Mail irgendwie Kämpel sendet, dass man dann sagen kann, die haben sozusagen ihr Schutzbedürfnis verwirkt?
Das hängt dann vom Richter, aber leider Gottes ist das Geheimnis im Gesetz nicht definiert. Sondern hängt dann vom Einzelfall ab, auch wie hoch ist das Geheimnis einzuschätzen? Ist das jetzt eher ein Geheimnis, wo man hohe Sicherheitsmaßnahmen erwarten kann? Oder ist das eher ein Geheimnis, wo man die geringer ansetzen kann?
Ich meine, es gibt ja in diesen Computer-Straftatkatalogen im 202a also den Ausspähen von Daten, über das Hacker häufig stolpern ja auch die Einschränkungen des Gesetzgebers, dass das nur dann illegal ist, wenn die Daten besonders gegen Auslesen geschützt sind.
Das ist richtig, ja.
Und insofern ist da ja auch schon angedeutet, also wer sich nicht um seine Daten kümmert, der...
Ja, aber schon auch bei der anderen Definition nach, also für den 17. UWG, was die zentrale Norm ist, im Arbeitnehmerverhältnis. Ja, das ist das Gesetz gegen unlauteren Wettbewerb, genau. Auch da, nach der Definition muss das Geheimhaltungsinteresse irgendwie manifestiert sein. Also wenn ich eine Sache in einem Journal veröffentlicht hab, dann ist es eben schon nicht mehr.
Ja, die Frage ist, kann man heutzutage schon behaupten, wir haben heute noch keine Sendung gemacht über Echelon und den ganzen Abhörkrempel, aber kann man nicht eigentlich schon sagen, wenn Leute unverschüssete Faxe schicken und unverschüssete Telefongespräche führen, dass sie es dann sowieso vergessen können? Also sie das auch juristisch vergessen können, weil sie dann einfach sozusagen ihr Schutzbedürfnis nicht hinreichend dokumentiert haben?
Also soweit würde ich nie gehen. Also wie weit kommen wir denn da hin, wenn man nicht mehr am Telefon davon ausgehen kann, dass das, was ich am Telefon spreche, dass ich das vielleicht erwarten muss, dass dann jemand ausspäht. Ich darf mich dann nicht wundern, wenn das passiert, aber dass mir dann das Schutzbedürfnis abgesprochen wird. Also dass ich dann sagen kann, dann darf ich mich aber nicht mehr darauf berufen oder gegen den vorgehen, der das gemacht hat. Das wäre wohl dann zu weit geschossen. Letztlich muss man da verworren und muss den Leuten sagen, sie müssen damit rechnen, dass das passiert. Aber ihnen dann zu sagen, wenn es passiert, wenn eure Faxleitung abgehört wird, sei das selber schuld. Ihr könnt dann gegen den auch rechtlich nicht mehr vorgehen, weil dann würde man das ja erlauben. Dann sagt man, jeder darf Faxleitungen anzapfen.
Aber mal zum konkreten Beispiel. Dieses Siemens-Angebot zum ICE soll ja, also der eigentliche Fehler soll in einer betriebsinternen Abstimmung zwischen dem deutschen Mutterhaus und dem südkoreanischen, der Niederlassung dort geschehen sein. Dass die also zwischen Deutschland und Südkorea unverschlüsselt per Telefax das hin und her geschickt haben. Die eigentliche, möglicherweise nicht rechtmäßige Tat, das Abhören hat sich also mindestens vermutlich außerhalb der Monologie Deutschland abgespielt. Und das heißt, die Möglichkeit da jetzt irgendjemanden für zu bestrafen, das kann man ja offensichtlicherweise total vergessen. Sehr gering. Und deswegen ist meine Frage, ob man wirklich sich damit einen Gefallen tut, wenn man so tut, als könnte man jemanden sozusagen dafür belangen. Weil nochmal, also das Tolle am Datendiebstand ist ja, es fehlt nichts. Also die Möglichkeit da jemanden zu erwischen, ist ja in der Regel auch nicht gegeben.
Das ist richtig, deswegen, die rechtlichen Instrumente sind immer sehr begrenzt. Und das Interessante ist ja, dass die Unternehmen, selbst wenn sie ausspioniert wurden, oder ein Arbeitnehmer da irgendwas an die Konkurrenz geliefert hat, es kommt ja nicht zu Prozessen. Also es kommt zu ganz wenigen, manchmal Zivilprozessen, aber zu Strafprozessen, obwohl alle beschreien, wie hoch die Schäden sind von 20 Milliarden im Jahr und was da auch für Deutschland angegeben wird, zum Teil in Amerika dann von 50 Milliarden im Jahr, die Rede ist, es kommt aber zu keinen Prozessen. Niemand stellt Strafantrag gegen den Arbeitnehmer, damit dann der Staatsanwalt ermittelt, ja was ist denn da jetzt passiert, letztlich wird er gefeuert. Und die Unternehmen ziehen sich, die wissen zwar, es gibt den rechtlichen Schutz als letztes Mittel nach, aber die ziehen sich doch darauf zurück, dass sie versuchen eben ihre Faxleitung zu verschlüsseln oder sonstige Schutzmechanismen in ihre Computersysteme reinzubringen. Also dieser rechtliche Schutz, man weiß, dass es den gibt und dass man auch, obwohl die Faxleitung nicht verschlüsselt war, man vielleicht da was machen könnte. Aber dadurch, dass man im Prozess ja auch jetzt Beweis führen müsste und dann im Prozess auch, um das zu beweisen, unter Umständen mit bestimmten Geschäftsgeheimnissen agieren müsste, wird das kaum, also wird dieser rechtliche Schutz kaum wahrgenommen.
Sind dir da irgendwelche Statistiken bekannt, wie viele Verfahren da nicht geführt wurden?
Ich hab mal recherchiert zum 17. UWG, was die Zentrale Norm ist. Da gab es strafrechtliche Entscheidungen, die konnte man an zwei Händen abzählen. Und selbst wenn es zu einem Strafverfahren kommt, ist ja oft wie im Wurzelstrafverfahren, es wird dann eingeleitet, wird ermittelt und dann wird irgendwann eingestellt gegen Auflage. Deswegen hat man kaum mal eine gerichtliche Entscheidung, wo ein Richter gesagt hat, so und so wird der abgeurteilt. Und die Strafrechtleinstellungen, da kommt man kaum ran, die werden kaum veröffentlicht. Und dadurch ist das alles in eine Zone, die rein von der Gesetzesanwendung her sehr schwer zu recherchieren ist. Eine interessante Sache vielleicht noch, ich hab das mal verglichen mit anderen Ländern. Eine Besonderheit in Deutschland ist ja, dass die Arbeitgeber, nach denen sie wenn sie ausgeschrieben sind oder zur Konkurrenz gewechselt sind, frei sind. Also wenn ich jetzt bei, was weiß ich, irgendwo gearbeitet habe im Unternehmen und jetzt abgeworben werde von der Konkurrenz, kann ich in dem neuen Unternehmen alles, was ich bei meinem alten Unternehmen gelernt habe und dort auch unter Umständen mir kopiert habe, frei verwenden. Es gilt nur, solange das Dienstverhältnis anhält bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber.
Darum konnten sie Lopez nicht an die Konchones.
Das ist ganz schön, das ist aber in anderen Ländern normal. In Russland z.B. gilt das nicht. Da gibt es keine zeitliche Beschränkung.
In Russland da gilt ja nichts.
Ich habe das mal mit Russland verglichen. Die haben das schon auch gut geregelt und es ist zum Teil einiges besser geregelt als in Deutschland.
Es gibt gelingtlich in Arbeitsverträgen Konkurrenzausschlussklauseln. Wenn man ausscheidet, darf man dann ein halbes Jahr oder ein Jahr oder zwei Jahre nicht bei der Konkurrenz anfangen. Was man wissen sollte, wenn man als Arbeitnehmer eine Klausel im Vertrag hat, ist, dass der Arbeitgeber verpflichtet ist, 50% des Gehalts weiterzuzahlen.
Das kann alles sein. Zivilrechtlich wird da vieles vereinbart. Man kann dann eine Klage des Arbeitgebers gegen sich haben und da eventuell Geld bezahlen müssen. Das kann sein. Man kann aber nicht strafrechtlich, der Staat kann nicht ankommen und sagen, jetzt stecken wir dich dafür ins Gefängnis.
Und das geht in Russland? Vielen Dank für deinen Anruf, Andreas. Und gute Nacht. Sieben Minuten nach Mitternacht. Hier ist Chaosradio 96. Wirtschaftsspionage unser Thema heute in der Sendung. Ihr ruft an und erzählt eure Wirtschaftsspionage unter 03317 77 9110.
Das ist richtig Rackenhol, wie es sein muss, gesellschaftskritisch wirklich wunderbar.
Chaosradio 96, das ist was ihr hört auf Fritz, 0331 77 97, ansonsten soll die Nummer, die ihr aufgefordert seid, anzurufen, um eure Geschichten zu erzählen zum Thema Wirtschaftsspionage. Das ist nämlich das Thema heute Abend hier im Chaosradio. Und angerufen hat der Ingo. Hallo Ingo.
Na inzwischen gab es hier schon Zweifel, ob das überhaupt am Thema ist. Ich dachte, vor der Jahrtausendwende zu Zeiten der Deutschen Demokratischen Republik habe ich Datenverarbeitung gelernt und da ziemlich zum Ende meiner Ausbildung Räder war es kennengelernt, ein Räder-Personal-Lautbanksystem.
D-Base, oh Gott, da muss ich auf der Schule auch irgendwie, das habe ich überhaupt nicht begriffen. Na ja, ich gehe dann schon mal.
Na ja, aber das war genau das D-Base. Und also da haben sie sich sozusagen die Mühe macht, das zu neutralisieren. Aber es war ja Cloud. Wobei die Frage ist, ob Software, die überall genutzt wird, überhaupt in dieses Thema Wirtschaftsspionage hineinfällt. Also ob der Software nicht sowieso... Also ich habe einen Handbuch gefunden, da stand erst mal eine Sicherheitskopie machen und nur mit der Sicherheitskopie arbeiten. Das wäre ja sozusagen schon einfach obkopieren.
Du meinst, sie haben einfach gemacht, was im Handbuch stand und deswegen kann man ihnen das nicht übelnehmen?
Ja genau, das war keine Wirtschaftsspionage. Also es ist ein Tool, das muss man benutzen Was jetzt?
Wirtschaftsspionage?
Nö, also Werkzeuge an sich. Aber wenn man jetzt Software klau, ist ja vielleicht nochmal was ganz spezielles. Wirtschaftsspionage, wenn man jetzt sagt, hier Angebote unterwegs irgendwo abhören und so. Das ist ja eine andere Schuhgröße als Software klau.
Oder?
Das ist natürlich frech, gleich irgendwie alles zu klauen plus den Namen zu ändern, obwohl es ja natürlich noch mehr Beispiele gab. Ich glaube, ein DOS-Klon, ein CPM-Klon, CPM hieß glaube ich SCP, oder das DOS hieß, weiß ich nicht mehr.
Also es kam neulich eine Meldung, es gibt ein Computerspielemuseum und die haben einen der, ich glaube sieben gebauten Automaten, das war irgendein, nicht Pac-Man, aber irgendeine Legende von Videospielen, das haben die DDR eben nachgebaut und die sind eigentlich alle, hieß es vernichtet worden, 1989 und einer ist eben jetzt noch gefunden worden und der wird jetzt einmal im Monat angeschaltet in diesem Museum, da kann man dann ganz vorsichtig spielen, weil es gibt halt auch keine Ersatzteile, also wenn da was kaputt geht, ist halt Ende.
Na aber das ist doch ein klassisches Wirtschaftsspionage-Thema, da gibt's sogar einen Film drüber, Tron, wo sozusagen der Protagonist irgendwie seine Spiele verloren hat, weil der Chef ihn die geklaut hat und die sozusagen, naja, ihr kennt den Film wahrscheinlich besser.
Ja gut, also man unterscheidet ja in der Diskussion wissenschaftlich, es ist Wirtschaftsspionage im Gegensatz zu Industrie-Spionage. Also Industrie-Spionage nennt man auch Konkurrenzspionage, wenn sozusagen Unternehmen mit technischen Mitteln sich gegenseitig in die Daten gucken oder jemanden bestehen oder was auch immer. Und Wirtschaftsspionage ist eigentlich der Begriff, wo es tatsächlich darum geht, dass Regierungen involviert sind, die dann für ihre lokale Wirtschaft, also auf volkswirtschaftlicher Ebene sozusagen Daten organisieren und beschaffen, also das, was jetzt im Kontext echelon und so fort passiert ist.
Aber unter dem Gesichtspunkt könnte das dann mit diesem Reda-Bars D-Base wieder mal sozusagen der Erfolgsgeschichte von Wirtschaftsspionage im Wesen sein, weil das ja sozusagen die Volkswirtschaft in einer Art und Weise beflügelt hat.
Ja, aber letztendlich hat es der DDR ja in so einem Fall nicht geholfen und nicht mal den DDR-Bürger als geholfen, sondern die Allianz, wenn ich mich recht im Sinne konnte, dann einfach die kompletten Versicherungsdaten der DDR elektronisch importieren, ohne dass sie irgendwie sich noch groß in Pasa schreiben mussten oder was, sondern die konnten einfach Import sagen und fertig.
Dazu sind Standards da.
Na ja, super.
Ja und dann gab es noch eine Frage, also wenn man jetzt sozusagen, also Dokumente, die mit geheimen Geheimverschlusssachen oder was auch immer, wenn die jetzt irgendwie so auf Flughäfen verbaselt werden, dann kann man ja sozusagen Leute, die das finden und wahrnehmen, nur schwer dafür belangen. Aber wie ist das mit der Veröffentlichung? Also wenn das jetzt sozusagen... In der Datenschleuder auftaucht? Naja, das ist ja sozusagen ein exemplarischer Fall. Aber wenn das in der Datenschleuder auftaucht, ja, dann hat das eine Redaktion und ein Verleger und der Verleger sagt dann auch, ich weiß gar nicht, wo das Monoskript hin ist. Das habe ich verlegt, das ist meine Aufgabe.
Ja gut, da gibt es ja einmal den urheberrechtlichen Schutz, der möglicherweise dazu kommt. Da hätte dieser Jurist uns eben noch mehr zu erzählen können. Aber das Thema kennen wir ja. Und dann gibt es aber auch noch die Frage der zivilrechtlichen Schadhaftmachung, wenn es irgendwie eindeutig nicht zu veröffentlichen bestimmt war. Da gibt es dann noch so eine Eskalationsnummer.
Na, aber wenn der Chaos Computer Club zum Beispiel die Maschinenlesbare Bundesregierung oder überhaupt so was fordert und man halt sagt, das geht nicht, weil das ist halt alles geheim irgendwie, das weiß nicht mal die Fraktion. Na ja, egal. Und dann aber sozusagen, was für sich halt da Sicherheitsloch, unverschlüsselte Kommunikation oder was auch immer halt dazu führt, dass man halt jetzt doch irgendwie die Maschinenlesbare Bundesregierung hat und man halt sozusagen das mal irgendwie im Spiegel betrachtet. Das war vorhin irgendwie mal ein Thema, sich im Spiegel betrachten, wäre es ja wenigstens noch wert. Bezugt sich das irgendwie Hüste auf morgens Zähneputzen oder dieses Blatt keine Werbung?
Ja, und dabei keine schlechte Laune kriegen, glaube ich.
Genau. Also wie ist das, wenn das dann im Spiegel steht, dann statt einer Datenschleuder irgendwie, dann ist das doch toll irgendwie, oder?
Na ja, es kommt ja immer noch an, was da steht. Und beim Spiegel ist ja meistens nicht entscheidend, was da drin steht, sondern was fehlt. Also was sozusagen in der scheinbar lückenlosen Aufklärung und die Wahrheit TM eben in der Betriebssicherheitszeitung der Bundesrepublik, was da eben nicht steht.
Das ist das ehemalige Nachrichtenmagazin.
Ich glaube, wir müssen jetzt nochmal.
Wir telefonieren ein bisschen weiter. Ingo, danke für deinen Anruf.
Ich danke auch. Ja, nochmal zurück, weil wir gerade dabei waren. Das gab es von mehreren Unternehmungen dann. Das CPM ist netterweise weiterentwickelt worden von der Akademie der Wissenschaften. Die hieß dann CPA. Und ist vom Koerner Kraftwerksanlagenbau entweiterentwickelt worden, da hieß es TPK. War übrigens ganz interessant, dass konnte dann 800K das Kettenlesen. War was ganz Irres, weil Standardformat war ja bis 624. Und da waren die richtig gut drauf. Kann ich mich noch nicht dran erinnern. Das waren so die ersten Versionen, die auf dem U880 dann so recht weit verbreitet worden sind. Ja, da hat man das nicht nur übernommen, sondern vielleicht auch produktiv etwas weiterentwickelt.
Ja, das wäre ja sozusagen...
Das ist dann so die Idee der Japaner oder so.
Ja, weiß ich nicht. Die Japaner, ich weiß nicht, ob die eine Schuld zu sein haben.
Die Chinesen haben gerade Ärger mit Cisco wegen sowas gehabt. Cisco hat eine chinesische Firma verklagt, ich glaube sogar vor der Wipo, weil die eben ein Gerät auf dem Markt hatten, was aussah. Wiener Cisco, Rochwiener Cisco, Tag genau Wiener Cisco. Aber das Betriebssystem hieß halt irgendwie ein Buchstaben anders.
Aber das, was wir vorhin sagten, von wegen Aufschleifen der Prozessoren, das war heute auch noch üblich.
Ja, nur sind die Strukturen heute ein bisschen feiner, da wollen wir ein genaueres Gerät haben.
Mit Schleifen und Ätzen ist da wohl nicht mehr allzu viel zu machen, das ist wohl wahr. Aber untersucht werden sie, denke ich, trotz allem immer noch.
Also was es gibt, sind Labors, die nachgucken, ob vielleicht Leute Patente verletzt haben. Also es ist nicht mehr üblich, dass man komplette Designs, komplette Layouts klaut, indem man da Fotos macht. Aber es gibt schon Büros, die man beauftragen kann, doch mal nachzugucken.
Ja, das schon. Aber ich denke schon, dass auch einer vom anderen zumindest das Interesse hat, zu wissen, was er in Zukunft vorhat.
Das auf jeden Fall.
Sagen wir es der Einfachheit halber mal so, ob man es da nachbaut oder ob man sagt, ne, das machen wir einfach nicht, weil das nicht in unserer Designpass steht. Das ist auf manchen anderen Fragen. Aber ich denke, man ist trotzdem im Interesse daran, wenn man auch irgendwie noch kompatibel bleiben will, etwas Ähnliches zu bauen.
Ich erinnere mich an einen Computer, die Überreste. Ich glaube, der stand auch an der Akademie der Wissenschaften original. Weil die Überreste sind jetzt in der Ziebelz, in der Hungestraße 20 zu bewundern. Ich weiß nicht, was das für ein Gerät ist. Das ist wohl ein IBM 360 Nachbau.
Also so ein Teil steht auch in der FU Berlin rum. Das ist sehr nett.
Sicherlich nicht mit gemischter deutscher, englischer und russischer Beschriftung. Also leider nicht mehr funktionsfähig, aber man kann sich das auf jeden Fall noch angucken, wie das aussieht, wenn irgendwie verschiedenste Technologien von links und rechts zusammengewickelt werden.
Und der Sören ist auch nochmal da.
Ja genau, ich warte eigentlich den ganzen Abend schon auf die Anacon Geschichte.
Die Anacon Geschichte?
Die haben wir ja gar nicht auf der Liste musik gesteht.
Die haben wir nicht auf der Liste? Sören, möchtest du gerne die Anacon Geschichte erzählen?
Anacon baut Windkraftanlagen und die wollten Mitte der 90er, ich glaube 94 ist das gewesen, in die USA exportieren, irgendwo in Texas, einen großen Windpark bestücken. Und haben dann da fröhlich ihre Verhandlungen geführt und irgendwann kriegte dann der Geschäftsführer eine Vorladung für irgendein Distriktgericht in Washington und wurde wegen Patentverletzung verklagt. Und da sind also tatsächlich irgendwelche Amerikaner irgendwann im März in Ostfriesland bei einem Landwirt in die Windkraftanlage eingebrochen und sind da hochgestiegen und haben die fotografiert. Alles da drin und mit diesen Fotos und so weiter. Das ist dann irgendwo, während diesen Verhören haben das die Ostfriesen zu sehen bekommen, da die Fotos aus ihren eigenen Anlagen, die dann sozusagen zur Grundlage gemacht wurden, dass sie Patente verletzt hätten oder eben auch nicht. Und die sind dann verurteilt worden, dass sie für 10 Jahre lang wegen der Gefahr von Patentrechtsverletzungen nicht in die USA exportieren dürfen. Ja, so kann man das ausdrücken.
Ja, in dem Kontext gab es auch noch irgendeinen Aspekt mit Telekommunikation zu überwachen.
Ja, wenn ich mich recht entsinne, haben sie wohl die Firmenkommunikation irgendwie abgehört.
Von Anacon auch?
Ja, von Anacon und dann dadurch überhaupt erst das Sicherheitssystem von diesen Anlagen geknackt, dass wir da hoch konnten, weil bei laufendem Betrieb hochzusteigen ist ein bisschen gefährlich.
Ganz genau, da gab es noch so eine Nummer, weswegen das auch, ich weiß, dass diese ganze Firma auch beim Echelon-Untersuchungsausschuss im Europaparlament mit drin war und das galt als eines der wenigsten Fälle, wo es sozusagen glasklar beweisbar war, dass die amerikanische Regierung sozusagen derartige Sachen im Interesse ihrer lokalen Wirtschaft, um nicht zu sagen, im Rahmen protektionistischer Allüren sozusagen betreibt.
Ja, und also ich meine, interessant ist dann ja auch die Reaktion der klugen Ostfriesen, oder?
Die kenne ich jetzt nicht, die da lauten.
Ja, daraufhin eigene Telefonleitungen genau rechtlegt für die interne Kommunikation.
Na halleluja.
Danke schön, Sören.
In Fritz in Sperrnberg? Dann nun da 3, 2.
Halb eins.
Fritz Info.
Mit dem Wetter nachts zieht der Regen langsam ab, die Temperaturen sinken auf 10 bis 7 Grad. Am Tage meist heiter und trocken bei 16 bis 19 Grad und die Meldungen meistens mit Matthias Kerkopf.
Der Koalitionsvertrag in Brandenburg zur Fortsetzung der rot-schwarzen Regierung ist fertig. Ministerpräsident Platzeck sagt am Abend, jetzt gehe es nur noch um die Struktur und um die Besetzung der Ministerien. Darüber soll heute entschieden werden. Künftig wird es eine Härtefallkommission für schwierige Asylfälle geben. Beide Parteien sind für die zivile Nutzung des Bombodroms in der Küritz-Rubiner Heide. Sie sprechen sich für eine Fusion mit Berlin aus. Die USA haben im Irak keine Massenvernichtungswaffen gefunden. Das wurde jetzt durch den Abschlussbericht ihrer Inspekteure offiziell bestätigt. Saddam Hussein habe jedoch den Ehrgeiz nie aufgegeben, seine Waffenprogramme wieder aufzunehmen. Die EU-Kommission hat Beitrittsverhandlungen mit der Türkei unter Auflagen empfohlen. Im Ausland ist das weitgehend positiv aufgenommen worden. Nach Berliner der Türkei erklärten, ein möglicher EU-Beitritt könne Stabilität und Sicherheit im Südosten Europas bedeuten. Auch die Bundesregierung begrüßte die Entscheidung. In Berlin werden die Preise für Trink- und Abwasser zum 1. Januar 2005 um durchschnittlich rund 5 Prozent angehoben. Das beschloss der Aufsichtsrat der Berliner Wasserbetriebe.
Vielen Dank, Matthias Karghoff. Zwei Minuten nach Albinz.
Hallo, Herr Radio Fritzen, ich bin Maxi.
Ich wünsche mir von The Streets Dryer Ice, Green Day, Outcast, Madonna, Blumentopf.
Damit grüße ich meine Schwester Sandra, Kumpel Benny, Leo, die einen verdammt großen Fehler begangen hat.
Meine Schwester Marie, Freundin Meike.
Einfach nur anrufen, wünschen und grüßen.
0331 70 97 130 Open Box. Die Musikwunscherfüllungsradio Sendung mit Grüßen. Immer Montag bis Freitag.
Ab 19 Uhr.
Uns im Radio.
Oh, da ist die Musik einfach mal alle. Ich dachte die liefen auch, weil du die ganze Zeit...
Das war jetzt gerade eine Einlage von Herrn Felix.
6 Minuten nach halb eins ist es Chaosradio 96 auf Fritz. Hört ihr und Wirtschaftsspionage ist unser Thema. Und falls ihr wollt, könnt ihr gerne anrufen unter 0331 70 97 110 und eure Geschichten zur Wirtschaftsspionage erzählen. Ansonsten wird Fefe das übernehmen.
Ja, also wir haben jetzt vielfach Spionage erzählt. Es gibt natürlich auch Leute, die sich Gedanken machen, wie man Spionage abwehren kann. Und die häufigste Sache, die wahrscheinlich viele Hörer schon am eigenen Leib erfahren haben, ist, dass inzwischen fast üblich ist, dass Firmen verbieten, Handys mit Kameras reinzubringen. Und seit ungefähr anderthalb Jahren, einem Jahr gibt es Handys, die sogar Filme aufnehmen können. Das heißt, allein Fotos ist auch gar nicht mehr so die Endbedrohung, sondern jetzt kann man also richtig Movies aufnehmen. Das ist relativ häufig, aber eine Story, also man munkelt sie, ich selbst habe das nie verifizieren können, man munkelt, dass bei Siemens in den internen Systemen, die für die Mitarbeiter zugänglich sind, absichtlich 50 Prozent Feeldaten eingepflegt wurden, damit wenn man was klaut, also man mit einer gewissen Wahrscheinlichkeit damit nichts anfangen kann. Vielleicht kann das ja ein Siemens-Mitarbeiter bestätigen.
Das wär's ja mal. 033 1797 1797. Wir brauchen dringend Siemens-Mitarbeiter, die das bestätigen. Also irgendjemand, der anruft und sagt, ist der Siemens-Mitarbeiter.
Dafür gibt es jetzt einen Windkraftwerk mit 5 Megawatt.
Ein Windkraftwerk mit 5, das ist ziemlich viel.
Das ist verdammt viel.
Bei der Gelegenheit wollte ich nochmal darauf hinweisen, dass wir auch noch den Chaos Communication Congress dieses Jahr haben.
Ach, mit Windkraft.
Genau, zukunftsorientierte Energien.
Mit Windkraft und mit allen anderen Energieformen vom 27. bis 29. Dezember Haus am... Für dich springen wir einfach auf. Also www.cdcde.com/kongress/2004. Und da gibt es auch jetzt schon ein Wiki zu mitmachen und jede Menge Krempels, ein Weblog und weitere elektronische Kommunikationsformen zur Vorbereitung dieses tollen Dingstars. Event. Event. Ja, genau. Dankeschön.
Wir sollten noch dazu sagen, dass wir dieses Jahr die Organisationen bestimmt nicht verpeilen.
Wir haben dies Jahr echt zu früh angefangen.
Dieses Jahr wird auch die Policy ordentlich enforced.
Genau. Auf jeden Fall.
Also dieses Jahr wird das der beste Kongress, den wir hier hatten.
Der beste Persil aller Zeiten.
Sie baden ihre Hände drin.
Nein, das war ja in den Spülmitteln.
Ach so.
Du bist echt ein Opfer der Werbung, kann es sein.
Bitte was?
Das muss nicht sein. Nein, Mühe allein genügt nicht. Ja, wenn Sie mal schauen möchten, hier ist Chaosradio 96 im Übrigen. Ein paar Minuten haben wir noch, haben wir noch irgendwas ausgelassen?
Ja, wir haben noch was ausgelassen.
Die höhere Anrufe.
Oh, ja stimmt.
0331 77 91 60, wollen wir noch nie auslassen.
Ansonsten gibt es noch eine Sache. Orkut ist so ein System, was vielleicht der eine oder andere schon gehört hat. Ich werde hier raus gemobbt. Also was ich sagen will. Früher war es so einer der teuersten Teile bei einer Industrie-Spionage-Aktion, war rauszufinden, an wen man sich wie heran macht. Und dazu gehört eben rauszufinden, wer sitzt auf wichtigen Positionen, was für Freunde hat er, was für Interessengebiete hat er, ja, was macht er gerne? Vielleicht wann hat er Geburtstag? Das ist so eine Ansprechmöglichkeit.
Hat er peinliche Hobbys, mit denen man ihn erpressen kann?
Genau. Früher war das eben so, dass man da richtig Detektive anheuern musste, die die Leute dann eben ausgespäht haben oder die die Mülltonnen durchwühlt haben. Und heute ist das so, dass die Leute selbst diese Informationen freizügig im Internet für jeden Lesbaren irgendwelche Datenbanken eintragen, die dann halt nicht Datenbank heißen, sondern, wie nennt sie auch gut? Keine Ahnung, Meeting, Blah.
Social Networking nennt sich das.
Social Networking ist der Begriff dafür.
OpenBC ist ja dasselbe, nur für Leute, die normalerweise Schlipse tragen. Aber eine Geschichte fällt mir auch noch ein. Und zwar muss man ja nicht unbedingt etwas ausspielen. Es gibt auch die Lösung, den ganzen Laden einfach zu kaufen. Das ist einem Kieler Unternehmen namens HDW passiert, die normalerweise U-Boote herstellen, unter anderem die, mit denen auch die Bundesmarine durch die Gegend fährt. Und naja, die hatten neulich einen Besitzerwechsel. Und der Besitzer war wohl offensichtlich auch glücklich, weil jetzt wird wieder ein neuer Besitzer gesucht, nachdem sie Blaupausen herausgetragen haben. Mal gucken, wer demnächst noch diese U-Boote bauen kann.
Ach, das war diese ganz leise U-Boote, ne?
Ja, genau.
So eine unheimlich progressive Waffe, finde ich.
Braucht jeder.
Na ja, ich habe ja gestaunt, dass jetzt gab es gerade eine Meldung, dass von den Kanadiern ein U-Boot vor Irland im Meer unnavigierbar ausgefallen tuckert und auf Rettung hofft. Das fand ich ja interessant, dass die Kanadier eine Marine haben, fand ich schon mal den ersten interessanten Punkt, aber dass die ein U-Boot vor Irland unterwegs sind.
Die Kanadier, die haben ja doch einiges an Küstenlinien, ne?
Ja, ja.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, es ist auf der Garte so.
Wundert nicht so viel wie die berüttene Schweizer Gebirgsmarine, aber fand ich schon bemerkenswert.
In den letzten Zügen liegt das Chaosradio nochmal 96 und wir haben noch einen Anruf von zwar den Robert. Hallo Robert.
Ja, schön, guten Abend. Ich hab noch eine kleine Geschichte hier mal mitbekommen. Da geht es um Datendiebstahl im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Das war nämlich auch ein Einbruch, wo dann aber der gesamte Server verschwunden ist.
Das war diese IBM Werbung, ne?
Alles weg, alles weg.
Es ging um eine kleine Firma, die machten irgendwelche Spezialeinfertigungen, ich glaub auch im Bereich Maschinenbau. Auf jeden Fall hat jemand den kompletten Rechner mitgenommen und damit waren die Daten dann wirklich auch weg, weil Backups wohl nicht vorhanden waren. Im Endeffekt hat sich herausgestellt, dass Kunden dann bei dieser Firma angerufen haben und haben gesagt, wir haben jetzt hier irgendwie Konkurrenzangebote bekommen. Und auf dem Wege hat sich das Ganze dann wieder aufgelöst. Am Anfang wusste man natürlich nicht, dass da irgendjemand absichtlich an die Daten wollte.
Was heißt wieder aufgelöst in dem Zusammenhang?
Durch diese Rückrufe von den Kunden ist halt rausgekommen, dass die Konkurrenz dahinter steckte und den Server entwendet hatte.
Hat die Konkurrenz denn dafür auch eins auf die Finger gekriegt?
Das habe ich hinterher leider nicht mehr genau mitbekommen. Das war wohl anfangs natürlich nicht nachweisbar, dass die das waren, weil keiner wusste, wer da eingebrochen ist. Ich habe halt nur so diesen ersten Teil von der ganzen Aktion mitbekommen. Und dass das halt irgendwie ein sehr schlechter und deutlich schiefgelaufener Versuch war, da irgendwie zu seinem eigenen Vorteil die Daten im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes zu klauen.
Ich frage mich auch immer, warum Fünfte ein Risiko eingehen. Also das ist doch klar, dass man da extrem aufpassen muss, dass man mit sowas nicht auffällt.
Ja, natürlich. Das hat sich derjenige aber wohl vorher nicht so genau überlegt. Das war dann halt sein Pech. Ob er im Endeffekt dafür richtig Ärger bekommen hat, weiß ich nicht. Aber allein die Blödheit, sowas überhaupt zu machen in einer Branche, wo es wohl gar nicht so viele Anbieter gibt, dann die Kunden anzurufen, zu sagen, wir können das irgendwie billiger. Und die Kunden haben dann halt ihren ursprünglichen Lieferanten Bescheid gesagt. Und dann war die Sache halt im Prinzip erledigt.
Muss man sich auch überlegen, will man bei jemanden kaufen, der seiner Konkurrenz die Daten klaut? Das ist nicht vertrauener weg.
Wenn es billiger ist?
Na, die können dann die Wartung noch nicht. Wenn die ganze Historie nicht kennen und wissen, warum das jetzt so aussieht, können die das doch nie reparieren.
Na gut, das ist dann aber abhängig vom Produkt.
Na ja, klar.
Ja, also das war auf jeden Fall noch so eine kleine Geschichte, die ich kurz erzählen wollte.
Vielen Dank, Robert.
Ja, gerne.
Tschüss. Wir sind am Ende angelangt von Chaosradio 96. Das war Wirtschaftsspionage. Chaosradio 97 gibt es dann meines Wissens wieder am letzten Mittwoch im Oktober. Andy macht die Jacke zu. Darf ich mein Lieblingslied zum Ende? Also ich hab doch diese neue Chaosradio Hymne.
Genau, wir haben gerade eine Münze geworfen.
Wollen wir noch mal eine Münze?
Wir werfen noch mal eine Münze. Sobald ich zweifle, das Ergebnis nehm ich an.
Also Kopf ist, wir spielen die neue Hymne und Zahl, was spielen wir dann?
Dann drücke ich nochmal die Taste. Wo ist denn die Warteschleife? Scheiße, hier ist sie.
Die Warteschleife?
Ja, die hab ich schon, alles klar. So, wie geht's jetzt? Den dann nimmst du dann?
Weiß auch nicht, ist irgendwie komisches Geld.
Das Perpetuum-Mobil, es ist erfüllt worden.
Ist doch ein bisschen...
Was war denn die Warteschleife?
Alles schieber, das ist jetzt Zahler der Kopf.
Dann mach doch mal die Warteschleife und ich mach hinten dran die neue Hymne.
Genau.
Vielen Dank, liebe Höhrende, und wenn ihr euch euren Lebensabend versüßen wollt, immer die Kundendaten aus eurem Arbeitgeber raus tragt, lasst euch nicht erwischen.
Naja, also das ist jetzt aber ein komisches Wort zum Sonntag.
Also das ist nicht schlecht, also schlecht fand ich das nicht.
Nein, okay. Und wenn ihr euch über die technischen Möglichkeiten euch nicht erwischen zu lassen, weiter informieren wollt, dann irgendwie kommt man zum Chaos-Communication-Konkret.
Ja, es geht jetzt weiter.
Nur der Nightfly mit Martin Peters Maus.
Olga Klein.
Bitte haben Sie noch etwas Geduld. Es wartet noch eine Person vor Ihnen. Bitte haben Sie noch etwas Geduld. Es wartet noch eine Person vor Ihnen. Bitte haben Sie noch etwas Geduld. Es wartet noch eine Person vor Ihnen. Bitte warten Sie. Bitte haben sie noch etwas.